[Musique]
Benjamin Bayard Marc R, bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Euh moi en
premier, apparemment, vu que c'est à moi
que tu fais signes, euh Benjamin Bayard,
ingénieur informaticien, euh militant de
longue date pour la protection des
libertés dans le monde numérique,
euh
membre de de trop d'associations pour
les cités toutes, euh cfondateur de la
quadrature du net et président de la
Fédération des fournisseurs d'accès
internet associatif pour les les deux
plus gros morceaux.
Euh
beaucoup de sujets à mon actif sur ces
dans dans ces thèmes-là. Et sinon à côté
de ça, pour gagner ma croûte, je suis
consultant. Euh
Marc,
je suis le second donc j'imagine que
c'est à moi. Euh Marqueress, abonné
internet euh journaliste, devenu
rédacteur en chef euh après quelques
années passées euh sur les banques de la
fac de droit, les banques de la fac de
droit d'Ax en Provence et euh voilà,
lecteur compulsif du journal officiel et
de toutes ces ces choses que personne
pas grand monde ne lit. Et euh voilà,
donc on a décidé de vous inviter tous
les deux aujourd'hui pour parler tout un
stade de sujets des internets, du
numérique, de la copie privée, de la
géopolitique, de la data, du pass
sanitaire et des données exfiltrées dans
des sociétés qui ne nous appartiennent
plus. Benjamin Bayard, est-ce qu'on
pourrait parler un petit peu Est-ce
qu'on pourrait parler un petit peu de
la géopolitique des datas ? Qu'est-ce
qui est en train de se passer ? Est-ce
que le gouvernement français fait le
nécessaire pour que les datas françaises
ou européennes restent souveraines et ne
soi pas exfiltré dans des sociétés qui
sont le bras armé du gouvernement
américain ou entre autres d'autres
gouvernements ?
Euh alors le problème c'est que si tu
attaques par ça, il faut que je commence
par le long tunnel où j'explique
et ben ça tombe bien, on a pris des
pelles aujourd'hui
et donc on va creuser un petit tunnel.
Euh en fait euh le le fond de ta
question, il y a deux morceaux. Il y a
un morceau qui est purement euh
géopolitique économique et qu'on peut
traiter sans rien de particulier en
considérant que la data c'est comme du
pétrole.
Euh et puis si on veut comprendre un peu
plus finement ce qui se passe en Europe,
il faut comprendre la question des
données personnelles. Et en fait la
question des données personnelles, c'est
pas intuitif parce que contrairement au
business en contrairement au pétrole,
c'est pas du business, c'est autre
chose. Et donc faut expliquer. Alors tu
vas voir, il y a trois trois grands
morceaux qu'il faut raconter.
Raconte-le comme si tu expliquais à
Marc.
Alors ben non, je te l'explique à toi.
Toi qui pose les questions, Marc, il
sait déjà. Euh donc
moi je sais pas c'est ça.
Mais non, toi tu sais pas. Euh donc le
premier morceau qu'il faut avoir en
tête, ça ça se résume en un slogan qui
est l'ordinateur est fatal. Et ça c'est
un truc qui est pas intuitif.
Euh ça peut se raconter avec quelques
petits exemples. Euh 1970, tu as des des
démarches à faire auprès de
l'administration. Comment ça se passe ?
Bah, tu vas dans les locaux de
l'administration, tu prends un joli
formulaire en papier qu'on appelle un
serfa et puis tu remplis dans les cases
en cochant tout bien.
Euh et puis bah donc tu tu décris ton
cas, nom, prénom, adresse, tata, tata,
tatata. Et puis à un moment, il faut que
tu décrives ta situation. Il y a deux
cases prévues qui sont bleu et rouge. Or
toi manifestement tu es vert. Ton cas à
toi, c'est vert. Ça ça aux yeux. On peut
pas le rater. Sauf être daltonien. Mais
on voit bien que toi ton cas c'est vert,
tu peux rien faire face à ton
formulaire. Du coup, tu prends ton
formulaire où tu as rempli tout ce que
tu pouvais et puis tu vas au guichet et
puis il y a une personne au guichet,
humaine, pas plus bête qu'une autre, qui
voit bien que toi manifestement ton cas
c'est vert et cette personne va s'en
débrouiller. Elle va adjoindre une note
au dossier, mettre un postit, agrafer un
truc, laisser un papier pour son
collègue qui traitera dans les bureaux
plus tard pour expliquer que ça rentre
pas quoi. Que comme dans le père Noël
est une ordure. Ça dépend, ça dépasse.
Ça c'est 1970. Tu regardes le même cas
en 2020.
Et ben tu fais un peu de recherche, au
bout de 3 minutes de recherche, tu
trouves où est le formulaire en ligne de
l'administration. Tu remplis tout le
zinzin et puis bah on te propose pareil
bleu et rouge. Or toi tu es vert vu que
tu es toujours vert en fait. Et
du coup face à ce [__] d'ordinateur,
tu peux rien faire. Alors du coup tu
cliques sur le bouton pour avoir de
l'aide. On te dit que le champ est
obligatoire et qu'il faut choisir ou
bien bleu ou bien rouge. Tu fais OK, je
suis pas plus avancé. Du coup, tu
essayes le chatbot qui te propose que le
champ est obligatoire et qu'il faut
remplir avec ou bien bleu ou bien rouge.
OK, ça sert à rien. Ensuite, tu réponds
au questionnaire de satisfaction sur
l'usage du chatbot pour dire que c'est
de la merde. Puis tu essayes de
téléphoner à l'administration, tu
trouves pas de numéro de téléphone, tu
te bats, tu finis au bout de moues
emmerdements par te rendre dans un
guichet où tu vas croiser un humain qui
est tout aussi intelligent que la fois
d'avant. il voit bien que tu es vert,
sauf qu'il a le même logiciel que toi et
il peut plus laisser une note. Qu'est-ce
que tu veux agrafer une note sur l'écran
? Enfin, j'ai il peut plus rien faire.
Le plus souvent, il peut rien faire.
Donc ça, c'est ce que ce que ce que je
résume en l'informatique est fatal.
Quand un ordinateur
applique un modèle, il n'y a plus de
négociation possible.
Et c'est très particulier. Tu peux tout
négocier dans la vie, sauf avec un
ordinateur.
Tant que tu es dans une relation
d'humain à humain, la définition du réel
est négociable. Quand tu es dans une
relation d'humain à machine, il n'y a
plus de négociation du réel.
Un autre exemple que j'aime beaucoup,
c'est par exemple les histoires de
schéma de codage de caractère. Quand on
a négocié la norme ISO 8859
qui définit les codages de caractère, le
représentant de la France euh était pas
là ou pas assez réveillé à certaines
réunions et euh il a oublié deux euh
caractères importants qui sont le Y trma
majuscule et le E dans l'eau majuscule.
Et du coup euh il a fallu modifier la
norme plusieurs années plus tard où on a
créé une 15e page à la norme 8859 pour
inclure ces deux caractères là. Mais du
coup, si tu as pas le Y trema majuscule,
tu peux pas faire le panneau de
signalisation qui dit la rose parce que
la ville de Lail et rose, il y a un Y
trema dans le nom et on écrit les noms
des villes euh tout en capitale.
Et là, tu as encore cette idée de
l'ordinateur est fatal. Si si le si le
caractère n'est pas codé, tu peux pas
écrire le nom. Et du coup, on fait quoi
? On change la réalité.
Et tu vois si euh si l'ordinateur, il a
prévu que tu puisses faire 1,70 ou 1,80.
Si tu fais 1,75, on fait quoi ? On en
coupe un bout.
pour que ça rentre dans la case. C'est
ça l'ordinateur est fatal. Tu peux plus
négocier.
Ça c'est le premier morceau. Tu tu
retrouves ça sous plein de forme. Il y
en a une que j'aime beaucoup qui est
Cédric Ha honorable ministre qui a la
tristesse d'avoir un nom en une seule
lettre et des milliers de formulaires
informatiques qui expliquent que pour
saisir un nom, il faut rentrer au moins
deux lettres. Et du coup, il faut quoi ?
Il change de nom. Il va s'appeler Ou X
pour plaire à l'ordinateur. C'est ça.
L'ordinateur est fatal. Plus tu
informatises le monde, plus tu rends la
négociation impossible. C'est plus une
négociation sociale d'être humain à être
humain, c'est une non négociation avec
une machine.
Euh
le deuxième morceau à comprendre, euh je
le résume souvent en euh tout fichier
est une maltraitance
ou pour le dire de manière plus
réaliste, tout fichier est une
maltraitance potentielle.
En fait euh quand tu mets des gens dans
des fichiers, quand tu fais des fiches
sur les gens, tu cesses d'avoir une
relation d'humain à humain, tu te mets à
avoir une relation d'humain à objet.
Ça commence par des choses extrêmement
tanodines. Je sais pas, tu organises un
mariage, une barmidzva, une grosse teuf,
il faut inviter plein de monde. Tu vas
faire un plan de table, tu veux éviter
que ta copine trans soit à côté du
tonton raciste parce que tu sens bien
que ça va clasher toute la soirée. Ça
peut être marrant.
Ouais. Non, en fait, très vite, c'est
lourd pour tout le monde et ton but,
c'est pas que ce soit lourd pour tout le
monde. Et du coup, bah tu fais tes
petits des petits papiers avec les noms
des gens et puis tu fais ton plan de
table et cetera. Est-ce que tu as le
droit de faire des fichiers avec trans ?
C'est pas le sujet, jeen suis pas encore
là. Euh
quand tu fais ça, en fait, quand tu fais
ton plan de table en déplaçant les
petites les petits papiers, tu manipules
tes papiers comme des choses. Jamais tu
déplacerais tes potes comme ça. Jamais
tu déplacerais tes potes comme des pions
sur un échiquier. Au moins, tu leur
demanderais, tu leur parlerais, tu leur
dirais "S'il te plaît, est-ce que tu
peux ?" tu vois, tu tu aurais une forme
de négociation humaine de la chose et tu
les traiterais pas comme des objets.
En fait, quand tu crées un fichier euh,
tu crées la possibilité d'une
maltraitance puisque tu fais ce qu'on
appelle de la réification, c'estàd que
tu transformes un sujet humain en un
objet sur lequel tu vas appliquer un
traitement et ce traitement sera
inhumain. Alors, les les exemples sont
innombrables.
Est-ce que est-ce que on peut appliquer
ça sur le les fichiers S ?
On peut appliquer ça à tous les
fichiers. Et j'ai bien dit fichier pas
nécessairement informatique.
Le fichier des juifs de la préfecture de
police de Paris dans les années 40,
c'était un fichier avec des belles
fiches en bristole dans un dans un
classeur en bois. Il y avait pas
d'ordinateur dans la bataille et ça
servait manifestement à maltraiter les
gens. Le fait de mettre les gens en
fiche et ensuite de les manipuler comme
des objets, de les trier, de les
classer, de calculer dessus, tout ça
c'est de la réification. tu te mets à
manipuler des choses et plus à manipuler
des gens. Quand un médecin, il ne voit
que le dossier et il voit pas le
patient, il peut pas être en empathie.
Il peut pas comprendre ce que dit ce que
dit le patient. Il peut juste décider
sur un graphique, une statistique, un
chiffre. Il y a plus de relation
humaine. Et en fait le fait de remplacer
les gens par une fiche, c'est le début
d'une maltraitance ou d'une maltraitance
potentielle.
Et ces deux éléments-l sont
rigoureusement indispensables à
comprendre pour comprendre pourquoi le
le sujet des données personnelles n'est
pas dans le droit du business. C'est pas
du droit du commerce, c'est pas du droit
de la propriété intellectuelle. Tu ne
peux pas vendre tes données personnelles
pour la même raison que tu ne peux pas
vendre un rein. C'est pas possible parce
que tu es dans du droit des personnes
en France ou en Europe.
En France ou en Europe. Aux États-Unis,
les données personnelles sont plus
considérées comme une propriété privée
au sens ta bagnole ou ton blouson, un
truc que tu peux vendre, que tu peux
donner. En Europe, les données
personnelles sont considérées comme une
de tes propriétés au sens la couleur de
tes yeux. Tu peux pas vendre la couleur
de tes yeux, ça ça n'a pas de sens. euh
au sens euh ton prénom, ton âge, euh tes
goûts, le fait que tu aimes ou pas les
fraises, les mangues ou euh la tarte à
la rubarbe, ça c'est ce sont des
propriétés de toi, pas des choses que tu
possèdes, des choses qui te définissent
et en fait tes données personnelles te
définissent et tes données personnelles,
c'est toi.
Donc toute cette longue longue
introduction pour expliquer marque. Pour
l'instant, j'arrive à suivre mais parce
qu'il est très bon. Il est très
pédagogique.
On sait tous qu'il est très bon.
Là, tu l'as coupé alors qu'il sortait du
tunnel. Et
ouais, mais c'est pour ça qu'il m'a
coupé aussi. Il est malin.
Euh donc en fait, c'est pour ça que le
droit des données personnelles en Europe
s'inscrit dans du droit de la personne.
Il s'inscrit pas dans du droit du
business. Les droits de la personnalité,
c'est oui, les droits de la personne au
sens de la personne humaine. C'est c'est
à côté des droits de l'homme, c'est à
côté de du droit à l'intégrité physique.
C'est dans le même registre de choses.
C'est pour ça par exemple que le RGPD,
le règlement général sur la protection
des données en Europe, il définit la
protection des données personnelles des
individus. Le secret des affaires, le
secret des procédés, c'est pas son c'est
pas son problème, c'est pas son sujet.
Aux États-Unis, tu feras à peine la
différence entre les données
personnelles et les données secrètes
d'une entreprise. Tout ça sont des
données qu'il faut sécuriser, qui sont
sujetes éventuellement à monétisation,
qui ont une valeur et donc le fait d'y
porter atteinte correspond à un
préjudice économique. En droit européen,
c'est pas le cas. Le fait d'y porter
atteinte n'est pas défini par un
préjudice économique. On n' pas besoin
de démontrer que ça tape fait perdre du
pognon pour que il y ait une sanction.
Donc ça c'est hyper important à
comprendre.
Là-dessus, je peux enfin répondre à ta
question
qui était euh
en gros souveraineté euh sur la data.
Et l'État, qu'est-ce que fait l'État ?
Et ben souveraineté sur la data, la
question est de savoir est-ce que le
droit qui s'applique sur tes données
c'est le droit européen ou c'est le
droit américain ?
sur ton compte Facebook, sur toutes tes
données de trafic sur Google, sur toutes
tes stades d'utilisation duorn.
Quel est quel est le droit qui
s'applique ? Est-ce que c'est le droit
gisiner.com ?
Voilà. Est-ce que c'est le droit
européen qui s'applique ? Et donc quel
en cuir aussi ça marche ?
C'est pareil. Euh est-ce que c'est le
droit européen qui s'applique ? au quel
cas tes données sont protégées parce que
données personnelles et cetera et le
RGPD est extrêmement strict par rapport
au droit américain ou chinois ou de
beaucoup d'autres pays ou bien est-ce
qu'on considère que c'est le droit
américain qui s'applique et dans ce
cas-là tes données sont pas du tout
protégées de la même façon et peuvent
faire l'objet de monétisation de
commerce et cetera.
Ce que nous a dit la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne, c'est que le droit
américain n'est pas compatible avec le
droit européen et ne peut pas être rendu
compatible.
Le droit américain prévoit des cas pour
le gouvernement pour accéder aux données
sans protection particulière et avec pas
assez d'encadrement.
Et donc les services américains FBI,
NSA, CIA, tout ça, tous ces gens-là
peuvent accéder aux données personnelles
des gens et entre autres des Européens
sans contrôle suffisant et donc d'une
manière qui n'est pas conforme au droit
européen. Donc là, quand on parle de
souveraineté sur les datas et où on va
sur des sujets comme cloud souverain et
cetera, le l'axe central, c'est est-ce
que le droit qui s'applique, c'est le
droit européen ou est-ce que c'est le
droit américain ? Si c'est le droit
américain qui s'applique, le droit
européen est violé.
Marc,
beaucoup de choses à dire. Merci
Benjamin pour cette introduction et ce
voyage en tunnel. Donc sur alors le RGPD
en fait il il prévoit dans ces dans ces
dans ces 176 considérant introductifs
euh enfin il donne un petit peu la
doctrine, donne la température, il donne
il donne la température donc de ce
dispositif. c'est 99 artiers qui
arrivent par la suite et et justement en
fait il a quand même été calibré pour
fluidifier la transmission des données à
l'échelle de l'Europe. Et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on qu'on le législateur
européen a opté pour un règlement et non
pas une directive puisque le règlement
s'applique directement dans l'ensemble
des États-membres alors que la directive
elle elle s'arrête à mi-chemin et elle
demande une loi de transposition. Donc
il faut une courroie de transm de
transposition dans chacun des
Étatsmembres. ce qui laisse craindre
aussi bah des des impuretés dans cette
mise en œuvre du texte européen
puisque'en fonction des sensibilité
respective, peut-être un pays anglophone
va pas avoir la même la même sensibilité
à la donnée que qu'un pays je sais pas
moi latin. Euh voilà. Alors sur le la
question du du droit applicable, en
fait, elle est inhérente à à tout
problème juridique
qui se pose sur les écrans que l'on
parle de contrefaçon de donc de droits
d'auteur de de donc de propriété
intellectuel ou même de données. Et le
RGPD, il a il a tranché cette
problématique là puisque dans ces dans
ces premiers articles
est prévu les règles de de des règles de
souveraineté quelque part puisque le
RGPD s'applique dès lors qu'un
responsable de traitement, donc un
acteur qui va qui va manipuler va réfier
des données se situent donc en Europe,
mais il s'applique également à des
acteurs qui sont hors UE mais qui visent
le marché américain le marché européen.
le marché européen des résidents Europe,
je parle bien des résidents européens et
non pas des nationaux européens hein
parce que nationalité n'est pas inscrite
sur l'adresse IP et cette règle de
là-dessus tu as un élément de logique
non tu as un élément de logique
extrêmement intéressant c'est parce que
c'est du droit de la personne. Ce sont
du c'est un droit des résidents
européens quel que soit l'acteur qui
manipule leur données. J'ai j'ai assisté
à beaucoup de d'audiences préalablement
à l'entrée en vigueur du du règlement et
et systématiquement systématiquement les
gros acteurs du numérique dans les
premiers instants introductifs de ces
ces audiences, il rêvait que d'une
chose, c'est de dépayser, c'est-à-dire
prendre le le litige qui était devant la
cour française, devant une cour
française et l'envoyer aux États-Unis.
Vous comprenez bien que euh dans un tel
dispositif enfin le la pauvre victime
française hein qui se prévaut de ses
droits et ben elle est complètement
démuni. Donc là le RGPD il résout ça
puisqu'il dit que le le règlement
s'applique pour les responsables de
traitement basé en Europe mais également
pour les responsables de traitement hors
UE mais qui visent le marché européen.
Et là, du coup, c'est pas mal parce que
quelque part, on voit que les valeurs
qui sont draînées par ce ce texte, ce
règlement et bien par cette règle de
territorialité, bon c'est c'est un gros
mot juridique et bien elles vont pouvoir
contaminer positivement, hein, c'est pas
péjoratif, contaminer positivement ben
des pays
ou ess voilà, c'est beaucoup plus joli
essé mais ça c'est ton côté maille à
l'abeille ça et vont pouvoir essimer à
l'échelle de la planète les valeurs du
règlement euh par ce cette règle
territoriale qui est qui est toute
simple.
Alors, je te mets un petit coup de
question internet. On va être cach
comment s'articule les lois les lois US
ex extraterritoriales et le RGPD,
l'extra territorialité du droit US.
Je te prends un exemple, la NSA qui se
gave sur les mails du président de la
République, les mails de nos chefs
d'étatmajors, les mails de tout ça, de
nos élus et ainsi de suite. Est-ce que
l'Europe avec Sepra, elle va aller
réclamer justice face au grands grands
grands grands frères américains ?
En fait, c'est une règle, ça c'est un
problème de conflit de loi comme il y en
a et comme il y en a eu et comme il y en
aura.
C'est une règle, un problème de conflit
de loi et et ce problème là dont j'ai
pas la clé, je j'ai pas la clé, je suis
pas de teasing,
il est extrêmement compliqué à gérer
pour les acteurs qui sont pris en
étamment
à un acteur fenêtré comme Microsoft qui
d'un côté a ses son ADN comme ça qui est
tissé vers les vers les États-Unis et
puis de l'autre voit son activité au
quotidien qui est encadrée par le texte
européen. Alors que doit-il faire ? doit
respecter le droit américain ou
docilement ou alors
se coucher face au droit européen. Et
parole à Benjamin
et en fait c'est
un des enjeux juridiques de de pas mal
d'affaires en ce moment et
si tu regardes ça d'un pur point de vue
de juriste,
ces affaires là, ces sujets-là sont
montées jusqu'à ce qu'on a de plus haut
comme cours en droit qui est la cour de
justice de l'Union européenne qui est
dit le droit européen pour l'ensemble de
l'Union.
Et la CJUE dans la RCH REMS 2 a tranché
le sujet. Elle a dit euh le droit
américain n'est pas compatible avec le
droit européen parce que euh les accès,
je te disais NSA, FBI, CIA et cetera,
les accès prévus par le Cloud Act ou par
le Patriote Actezadrés.
Il y a pas de possibilité de recours.
Les cas dans lequels le gouvernement a
le droit d'aller piocher dans les datas
sont pas assez bien définis, sont pas
assez cadrés, il y a pas assez de
contrôle et cetera. Donc c'est pas
compatible. Maintenant, une décision de
cour suprême, ça a beau être la cour
suprême de l'Union européenne, euh tu
peux rien en faire dans la vie de tous
les jours. Il faut attendre que ça
redescende en pluie fine et pénétrante
dans la réalité.
Euh ça va pas redescendre du jour au
lendemain parce que ça n'aurait pas de
sens pour le coup en matière économique.
C'estd que c'est là où on bascule du
droit à une forme de géopolitique.
Euh tu peux pas avoir du jour au
lendemain toutes les knil d'Europe qui
prennent l'arrêt de la CJUE et qui
disent "OK, toutes les activités de tous
les acteurs sous juridiction américaine
sont illégales en Europe dès qu'il y a
de la data personnelle. Donc on ferme
AWS, on ferme Google Cloud Platform, on
ferme Microsoft Azure, on ferme Facebook
euh on ferme enfin on ferme tout. Euh il
va rester à peu près rien. Euh tu peux
pas faire ça. Tu peux pas faire ça.
Est-ce que
c'est pour ça Est-ce que c'est pour ça
que Macron a convoqué les 200 plus
grands intervenants du du numérique
français pour pas concurrencer les GAFA
mais pour se donner l'opportunité
d'avoir un plan B ? Est-ce que c'est
dans cette vision là ? Est-ce que Macron
a une vision à long terme ?
J'en sais rien. Faut lui demander à lui.
Je crois que non.
Ouais, il faudra l'inviter en fait pour
pour revenir
pour revenir ce que dit que sur ce que
disait Benjamin, je crois qu'il faut
quand même remettre les pendules à
l'heure à savoir que il y a une
responsabilité énorme de la Commission
européenne dans la problématique
aujourd'hui de la souveraineté des
données. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en 2000,
cette commission européenne, elle a
signé un blancin. Elle a signé le CFR.
SF Harbor qui était un accord euh un
accord juridique, hein. Bon voilà,
c'est Harbor qui veut dire
bah le port sûr quoi. Bon, c'est affreux
comme terme, mais concrètement qui
transforme les États-Unis comme une
comme une espèce de de d'État membre
européens bis où les les les protections
accordées aux données étaient
équivalentes à celles en vigueur, en
France, en Belgique, Luxembourg, peu
importe. Voilà. Et du coup, qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ? et ben les grands
acteurs américains ont pu mettre des
pipelines et aspirer et collecter de la
donnée par purge complète sur bah sur
nos épaule hein et ce pendant des années
et même au-delà et c'est c'est là où ça
ça a éclaté au-delà des révélations
Snowden qui montraient qu'il y avait bah
finalement que le ce fameux pays ports
sûr n'était pas si sûr que cela parce
que il y avait un accès assez privilégié
des autorités américaines de sécurité
sur les données draîné en en Europe et
que ça posait quand même souci. Et la
Commission européenne qui par communiqué
dénonçait euh ses ses atteintes bah n'a
pas pensé, n'a pas percuté, c'est pas
dit bah tiens, moi en 2000 12 13 ans
auparavant, j'ai signé un blanc sein et
j'ai pas j'ai pas remis en cause ce
dispositif. Elle a pas assuré la mise à
jour. Il a fallu que la CJE, la Cour de
justice Union européenne bah si enfin
siffle la la fin du match une fois et
même deux fois puisque l'accord SF
Harbor a été remplacé par un nouvel
accord, le Prima Bassy Shield qui a
donné naissance donc qui veut dire
bah le bouclier de données qui a donc
enfronté ensuite de l'arrêt Schrems 2
nom de ben de cet Autrichien autrefois
étudiant bah qui a qui a pu mettre à
terre ses ces deux dispositifs et et
donc Finalement dans dans les fin mot
d'histoire, on peut pas reprocher
finalement à ces acteurs à ces acteurs
américains que de vouloir grossir
puisque ce sont des sociétés
commerciales et c'est leur ADN de
vouloir euh voilà. Mais dans la
cette ce sens de l'histoire un peu
curieux, la responsabilité de la
Commission européenne, elle est
extrêmement lourde. Je sais pas ce que
tu en penses. Oui. Alors, elle est
extrêmement lourde et surtout ce qui est
intéressant, c'est qu'il y a un
changement de comportement. Euh en 2000,
la Commission européenne de l'époque si
signe le safe Harbor qui dit euh les
États-Unis sont un territoire aussi sûr.
En fait, États-Unis et Europe présentent
le même niveau de garantie pour les
données personnelles. Donc, les données
peuvent librement circuler parce que
tout le monde sait que c'est faux. Tous
les associatifs gueulent dans toute
l'Europe et la la Commission signe quand
même le truc et on on met très longtemps
à s'en défaire. Euh, on met une
quinzaine d'années, c'est en 2014 ou
2016 ? 2014, je crois.
2014. 2014 euh que le Safe Harbor est
cassé, la CJUE casse le truc et il faut
savoir que ça fait un coup de tonner et
le le lendemain euh de l'isue de la la
vie de l'arrêt de la CJIE qui annule le
texte, euh la commission euh dit "On va
préparer un nouveau texte, on va
travailler sur un nouvel accord
international avec les les États-Unis
sur la protection des données
personnelles, il va sortir hyper vite.
Data must flow. C'était ça le sujet, le
le late motif de la Commission
européenne à l'époque, c'était data must
flow. Et ils étaient en mode panique et
ils ont négocié en quelques semaines
parce que la décision date de novembre,
l'accord est prêt en février et il entre
en vigueur en juillet. Tu vois pour pour
négocier un accord international entre
novembre et février, on est d'accord,
c'est pas habituel quoi. C'est ils sont
en mode panique absolu. Euh 2020, donc
euh à peine 5 6 ans plus tard, on n'est
plus sur la même commission, c'est plus
la même législature. Le le paysage
européen a bougé.
Entre-temps, euh le règlement européen
sur la neutralité du net est passé alors
que les États-Unis se positionnent
contre la neutralité du net. Le RGPD a
été voté alors que il existait pas
encore et il a fait l'objet d'une
bataille parlementaire. Il y avait
jamais eu autant de lobbying au
Parlement européen que pendant la
discussion du RGPD où toutes les grandes
entreprises américaines sont venues
essayer de torpiller le truc et n'ont
pas réussi. Euh donc le paysage européen
a changé et quand la CJUE casse le
privacy Shield euh juillet 2020 si ma
mémoire est bonne euh la commission ne
réagit pas. Elle dit pas on va faire un
truc elle dit OKT on en prend note et on
va s'adapter.
Ça ça veut dire que quelque chose a
changé. On est passé d'un mode où data
must flow et il faut euh aider Google et
Facebook à faire du bon business en
Europe à un mode où OK, il y a
manifestement un interdit juridique fort
qui est tombé et ben on va faire avec.
Et et en fait mon impression est que il
est en train de se dessiner dans la tête
des des dirigeants européens
certaines souverainetés
l'idée d'une géostratégie,
l'idée d'une politique économique, le
truc qui est devenu un gros mot depuis
les années 60 et où en fait bah si on
veut qu'il y ait un écosystème du
numérique en Europe, il faut qu'il y ait
nos règles qui s'appliquent, pas celles
des autres et que du coup ça protège nos
acteurs parce que nos acteurs vont
appliquer nos règles et si les règles
américaines sont incompat compatible
avec les nôtres, ça va petit à petit
interdire le marché européen aux acteurs
américains.
Alors, je vous coupe, je vais vous poser
une question internet
juste juste après. Ma petite parenthèse,
vous avez suivi l'affaire avec le
Danemark. le Danemark qui s'est
transformé en en l'équivalent d'un
centre d'écoute de la NSA à cause de du
fait que ils aient laissé les services
américains utilisés le soit le CAP
sous-marin soit une partie de leur
infrastructure en leur permettant
d'écouter
nos communications, donc nos datas.
Est-ce que euh cette géopolitique
européenne qui est embryonnaire, cette
souveraineté européenne embryonnaire par
rapport aux États-Unis n'est pas
contourné par les États-Unis par des
chevaux de 3 au sein même de l'Europe et
sur nos câbles sous-marins pour pouvoir
avoir accès directement à ce qu'on
essaie de de de leur faire passer à
l'AS.
Est-ce que Paris est au Danemark ?
Moi, j'ai lu attentivement ce qu'il y
avait dans dans la loi renseignement en
2015. On l'a attaqué devant le Conseil
d'État et devant le Conseil
constitutionnel, en particulier les
morceaux sur les écoutes internationales
et où autant il y a un tout petit peu de
réglementation et il y a un certain
cadre juridique sur les écoutes que les
services peuvent faire en France. Autant
à l'international, c'est open bar. Donc
tu as le droit d'écouter pas tellement
les conversations de chez toi, mais les
conversations internationales, c'est
open bar. tu passes par copains pour
écouter chez toi
et et les échanges entre services, donc
les services allemands avec les services
français, les services français avec les
services américains, les services
américains avec les services danois. Les
échanges entre services, c'est open bar.
Donc
tu écoutes tout ce que tu veux à
l'international. Genre tu écoutes en
Allemagne, tu écoutes au Danemark, tu
écoutes tout ce que tu peux comme
conversation internationale et tu
échanges avec tous les services de la
planète et tous les pays d'Europe
s'amusent à faire ce genre de conneries.
C'est exactement ce qu' fait ce qu'a
fait le Danemark et c'est ce qui permet
euh aux services américains de
surveiller les dirigeants européens.
Mais la France fait pareil. Et donc
effectivement pour écouter François
Hollande, il passent pas par la DGSI qui
est le service français, ils vont passer
par le service danois. Mais pour écouter
Angela Merkel, si ça se trouve, ils
passent par la DGSI ou la DGSE qui sont
les services français. C'est c'est tout
un jeu d'échange. Et donc oui, les
États-membres ne jouent pas forcément le
jeu.
Ouais. Et là-dessus euh c'est pour ça
que j'ai enfin malgré le lecture de la
loi enseignement que j'ai j'ai un petit
peu étudié aussi et de la loi
surveillance de communication
internationale de 2015 fait que la vraie
loi renseignement pour moi c'est pas la
loi renseignement c'est la loi sur la
surance des communications électroniques
internationales parce que effectivement
elle est beaucoup plus généreuse et
beaucoup moins regardante sur le
formalisme encadrant les demandes
d'autorisation des libres au service
pour mener à bien ses ses écoutes entre
guillemets ou ses traitements de données
euh sachant qu'il y Il y a un point
central dans ces ces deux textes. Bah,
c'est là encore la territorialité qu'on
avait vu tout à l'heure avec le RGPD. À
partir de quand une communication
nationale devient-elle internationale ?
Alors, la loi renseignement ou celle de
la surveillance des communications
internationales parle de numéro
rattachables au territoire et cetera.
Mais si moi si Benjamin par exemple est
dans l'arrondissement d'à côté et moi je
suis à Tourcoin Strasbourg ou Marseille
peu importe et on échange via Gmail,
est-ce que notre numéro d'identification
euh bah c'est pas une espèce de machin
américain qui va surgir sur les écrans
et qui va permettre aux services de
renseignement de rattacher la
possibilité d'une écoute de cet échange
là qui est franco-français he mais avec
le dispositif beaucoup moins regardant
de la loi surveillance des
communications internationales.
et et d'autant plus qu'on a beaucoup
parlé des boîtes noires, le 851-3 du
code de la sécurité intérieure qui est
un traitement algorithmique qui est
destiné à anticiper d'éventuelles
menaces terroristes à l'aide des des
données des données de connexion ou des
données téléphoniques. Bref, euh en fait
quand on regarde la la loi sur la
surveillance des communications
internationales, on parle pas de boîte
noire ou de Mais par contre il y a il y
a il y a une expression, c'est le
traitement automatisé. Ils appellent ça
traitement automatisé. Non, maintenant
ils disent le la technique des
algorithmes.
Ouais. Algorithmes. Mais dans la loi
enseignement, on parle de traitement
automatisé.
la loi sur de communication des
communications internationales et et de
fait autant le le 850-3 qui est prévu
par la loi renseignement est
relativement cadré puisqueil y a il y a
quand même une commission nationale de
contrôle et technique du renseignement
qui est là en amont et en aval de la
mise en œuvre de cette technique mais et
et encore cette technique n'a pour
finalité que la lutte contre le
terrorisme ou la prévention du
terrorisme. Mais à l'échelle
internationale, on parle de traitement
automatisé mais pour l'ensemble des
finalités du texte. Les finalités de la
du renseignement sont extrêmement
vastes. Évidemment, il y a le terrorisme
qui est la la finalité aussi
épouvantail, c'est vraiment ce qui fait
ce qui mobilise les troupes. Mais
d'ailleurs, on a aussi la défense
d'intérêts
commerciaux et financiers importants à
l'échelle d'une nation. Et tout ça,
c'est ouvert au cas de vent. Vous vous
avez entendu parler d'une société qui
s'appelle Palentir ?
Alors oui, un petit peu. Qui qui n'a pas
entendu parler de Palentir ?
Est-ce que vous vous pouvez nous en
parler un petit peu ? Benjamin
Oh, alors je peux je peux en parler que
sommairement parce que c'est pas c'est
pas un dossier que j'ai beaucoup étudié.
Euh
complètera peut-être.
C'est c'est globalement un des
fournisseurs des services de
renseignement américain en matière de
matériel d'analyse du trafic euh
ressources.
la presse, mais c'est aussi de notoriété
publique. Tu vas sur leur site web,
c'est écrit, hein. Euh
donc c'est c'est une entreprise qui a
pignon sur rue, qui est membre de tout
un tas de comités de lobbying à
Bruxelles comme à Washington euh qui
travaille avec à peu près tous les pays
du monde. Je soupçonne que la France
achète quelques matériel chez pas
lentir, je sais plus. Euh il me semble
c'est oui que que il y a euh donc c'est
c'est une une boîte qui te fabrique des
des armes numérique si tu veux euh mais
qui
bah des outils quand c'est vraiment fait
pour être utilisé par des services de
renseignement pour attraper les
opposants. On n'est quand même pas très
loin de considérer que c'est des armes
numériques.
Ils ont fait ça.
Ah oui bien sûr. Mais le si tu veux les
marchandes se se cachent jamais d'être
des marchandes. Mais il t'explique
qu'ils sont pas antidémocratiques
puisque c'est le gouvernement qui est
démocratique et que
ressources pour le le palentir et les
opposants là.
Euh Palentir et les opposants alors en
Tunisie c'était Cosmos euh
je sais plus tu vois pour le coup.
Après, de manière très naturelle, si je
devais enfoncer des portes ouvertes,
entièrre Technologie est une entreprise
de services et d'édition de logiciel
spécialisé dans les analyses et la
science des données communément appelé
big data ou mégonné
basé à Denver.
C'est pas des marchandes.
Si au sens numérique. Si
ça n'engage que vous. Tu veux rajouter
quelque chose ? Non non, je disais
simplement c'est que dès lors qu'on a on
a des textes aussi ambitieux que la le
renseignement qui prévoient des outils
d'analyse de la donnée aussi bien la
donnée de connexion, c'est-à-dire tout
ce qui tous les toutes les données qui
encapsulent le contenu d'une
conversation ou alors des données qui
vont analyser ces conversations, quelles
a pour véhicule un mail, enfin le
contenu d'un courrier ou la voix ou de
la vidéo et cetera et cetera. Bah
forcément, c'est un un appel un appel du
pied à tous les acteurs commerciaux pour
développer des solutions euh qui soient
adapté à ce texte-là. Parfois même, on
pourrait imaginer euh que les textes ont
été adaptés aux capacités techniques de
ces de ces acteurs. Et
question internet,
vous voulez rajouter quelque chose ?
Non. Question internet. Que faire
lorsque le jugement de la CJUE ne sont
pas appliqués en France, notamment sur
la conservation des données des
opérateurs ?
Ah ! Alors ça ça c'est une c'est une
question qui est super amusante.
Deux choses. D'abord, un jugement de
cour suprême, ça s'appelle pas
question de Balthazar.
Euh un jugement de cour suprême, ça
s'applique pas de manière directe. Ça
prend du temps à à infuser, si je puis
dire. Euh il se trouve que la même
décision de la de la CJUE, celle qui
invalide le la conservation par les
opérateurs des données de connexion et
leur transmission euh pour toute
raisons, enfin pour énormément de
raisons, en tout cas beaucoup trop au
goût de la cour euh aux différents
services pour pour d'innombrables
motifs. Euh la même décision en France a
été euh appliquée en disant on ne change
rien alors que la cour nous dit que le
dispositif français n'est pas légal.
Donc on change en fait un peu de vernis
mais on change rien dans le fond. Et ça
c'est un arrêt rendu par le Conseil
d'État qui est l'arrêt French Data
Network. Euh et le lendemain, la Cour
constitutionnelle de Belgique rendait un
arrêt qui disait exactement l'inverse,
qui disait euh
tout le tout le volet juridique
belge sur la conservation des données de
connexion est déclaré contraire à la
Constitution et donc le Parlement belge
doit se saisir et réécrire le droit
correspondant et remettre ça au carré.
Donc ça c'est des différences entre état
membres. C'estàd que le le fait que tu
obtiennes euh une géopolitique euh un
peu ambitieuse ou qui se mettent en
place ou un peu embryonnaire au niveau
européen, si les Étatsmembres ont pas
envie de l'appliquer, ils vont y aller à
reculon, ils vont euh jouer contre leur
camp, ils vont euh traîner des pieds, ne
pas transposer, ne pas adapter, ne pas
gérer. Enfin euh tu fais pas boire un
anne qui a pas soif. Et le la bonne
volonté des États-membres est pour le
moment un des éléments qui manque. Mais
il y a un moteur qui a changé par
rapport à 2000 sur vraiment ce que
disait Marc tout à l'heure. Euh la
commission qui en 2000 et jusqu'en 2016
soutenait Mordicus le Saf Harbor et la
libre circulation des données avec les
États-Unis. Il y a eu un revirement au
niveau des institutions européennes. Il
y a il y a eu un revirement. Il est pas
éternel. Peut-être ça durera pas jusqu'à
la fin du monde, mais pour le moment, il
y a eu un revirement et il y a une prise
de conscience d'un certain nombre de
sujets autour du numérique sur le fait
qu'on peut pas faire n'importe quoi avec
les droits de l'homme en matière de
numérique. Et
les sanctions pour tout ça, c'est quoi ?
Bah, les sanctions prévues par euh par
les textes sont extrêmement élevées
parce que tu as bah sur le sur le RGPD,
c'est facile. Si tu n'as pas euh mis
1000 et moyens, c'est 2 % ou 100
millions et si tu as porté atteinte euh
aux données personnelles, c'est 4 % ou
20 millions. Euh alors le 2 % ou 4 %,
c'est 4 % du chiffre mondial, du chiffre
d'affaires mondial consolidé du groupe,
pas de la filiale française,
celle qui est positionnée en Irlande.
Non parce que ça ce serait la filiale
européenne. C'est le chiffre d'affaires
mondiales consolidé du groupe. C'estàd
que si tu fais un procès à YouTube,
c'est pas la petite filiale YouTube que
tu attaques. C'est pas le groupe Google,
c'est le groupe Alphabet.
Et l'amende maximum, c'est 4 % du
chiffre d'affaires mondial consolidé de
l'ensemble du groupe sur la planète. Euh
donc ça fait quand même potentiellement
des très gros sous. Et il commence à y
avoir, si tu veux avant la l'entrée en
vigueur du RGPD, la plus grosse amende
que l'ACNIL pouvait mettre, c'était
350000 €, si ma mémoire est bonne. Et
euh Google, c'était déjà payé l'amende
maximale une paire de fois et ça fait
rigoler tout le monde. Enfin, si tu veux
350000 € c'est même pas le budget petit
four.
Euh, ça n'est pas sérieux. Euh, la
dernière amende que l'ACNIL a posé sur
Google, c'est 100 millions d'euros.
C'est c'est ta faute d'ailleurs ? Non,
celle de 50 millions d'euros qui avait
été posé 1 an avant, ça c'est de notre
faute. C'était suite à une plainte de la
quadrature du net, euh celle de 100
millions d'euros. La CNIL s'en est
saisie toute seule.
En fait, pour en revenir à
tu vois les les montants montent et les
sanctions grimpent. Mais donc, tuas tu
as bien ce revirement géostratégique
côté européen et tous les États-membres
ne suivent pas et ils suivent pas tous
de la même façon. Euh
pour en revenir à la à la question plus
directement, bah il faudrait qu'il y ait
un recours en manquement. Il faudrait
que la Commission saisisse
éventuellement la CJE, la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne ou alors
qu'il y a un nouveau dossier qui monte
devant les juridictions pour pour faire
pour éprouver le le l'état de la
législation actuelle à l'instant té euh
aux yeux et aux oreilles à la bouche de
la la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne. Mais à chaque fois, c'est
des procédures qui prennent beaucoup de
temps, beaucoup de temps. Et ce temps-là
et bien c'est lorsque les situations
sont illicites et ben c'est un temps où
ben les violations de données
personnelles sont conséquentes. Elles
sont massives massives.
Question internet qui va vous paraître
un petit peu
légère.
Est-il possible d'utiliser internet pour
s'informer sans pour autant partager nos
informations personnelles sans le
vouloir ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
Alors
Marc, tu veux répondre ?
Euh je dirais non aussi. Enfin, si on
peut pas partager ses informations
personnelles, le mieux c'est de ne pas
aller sur internet. Enfin, c'est le la
solution la plus radicale qui soit. Mais
c'est un peu c'est un peu Mais vas-y,
vas-y.
En fait, parce que j'ai envie de
considérer d'abord que ce que j'appelle
les techniques de hacker n'existe pas.
Euh une technique que euh ma belle-mère
ou ma grand-mère ne peut pas utiliser
dans son canapé, j'estime qu'elle existe
pas. Le fait que moi je puisse utiliser
des outils un peu un peu bizarres, un
peu technique et cetera, ça a pas de
sens. Ça concerne 0,02 % de la
population. C'est pas un sujet. Hm hm.
Donc euh ce qui ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est ce qui se passe pour le grand
public, ce qui se passe en moyenne. Et
ce qui se passe en moyenne, c'est que
euh ta connexion au réseau est tracée.
Euh que ce soit ton téléphone mobile ou
ta bidule box, la connexion est un
minimum tracée. Le moindre site web
grand public te pose trous cookies
bannière bandeau de pub
pixel caché de tracking de machin. Ta
télé est tracée aussi.
Ta télé est tracée depuis qu'elle est
ton enceinte connecté portable.
Depuis que ta télé est numérique, elle
est tracée. Ton enceinte connecté mais
ça sert à te tracer. Enfin je dire c'est
un micro qui est chez toi pour écouter
si des fois tu poserais une question.
C'est un outil de surveillance. Il se
trouve qu' en théorie, il t'a été vendu
pour te surveiller pour répondre à tes
questions quand tu dis "Alexa, quel
temps il fait dehors." Mais euh
c'est bien un système de surveillance et
c'est tracé. Donc en moyenne si tu vas
sur internet, ça laisse des traces. Il y
a quelques endroits où ça laisse moins
de trac d'autres. Il y a des endroits où
ça n'en laisse presque pas. Quand tu vas
consulter Wikipédia, ça laisse presque
pas de trace. Il y a des endroits où ça
laisse tellement de traces que ça en
devient immonde. Euh genre n'importe
quel site de presse euh à part Next
Impact et euh
ou ou Facebook ou n'importe quel site de
cul encore. Que les sites de boule sont
moins invasifs que les sites de presse
grand public. C'est c'est pas faux.
Ils ils ont de la régie publicitaire
mais enfin si tu veux ils font de la
publicité. Ils sont 5 si entre eux. Ils
son c'est à peu près le même commerce.
Euh mais le tu tu vas sur euh tu tu vas
sur n'importe quel site de presse grand
public, le monde le Figaro euh et
cetera, le truc te demande ta
géolocalisation pour pouvoir te faire de
la publicité ciblée.
Jamais un site de boule m'a demandé ma
géolocalisation quoi. Tu veux tu vois
c'est rien que ça c'est moins invasif en
fait en vrai. Ils sont plus crapuleux
sur plein d'autres trucs mais pas sur
ça. Et donc le en vrai si tu veux aller
lire des infos sur internet, il faut
savoir que tu es traqué et et qu'en fait
le droit européen dit que tu as pas à
l'être
et tu as quelques sites qui traquent
moins. Mais
je dois consentir pour l'être.
Bah c'est pas clair en ce moment. C'est
pas clair.
Ah oui oui oui. Enfin non mais en
théorie dans la théorie
en théorie Ah ben après ça ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai que pour le coup le droit
européen est bien fichu. En théorie il y
a que six motifs possibles de lycéité
pour un traitement de données.
Lycéité il faut dire
léité
il faut dire
pour qu'un traitement de données soit
légal. Il y a six motifs prévus et il se
regroupe en trois grandes catégories ou
bien c'est ce que tu as demandé. C'est
que le traitement de données est
nécessaire à l'exécution du contrat.
Bah, typiquement, tu tu fais un site de
vente de casserole en ligne. Euh si je
viens sur ton site commander des
casseroles, pour m'expédier ma commande,
tu vas demander mon adresse postale, une
adresse mail pour me répondre. Normal,
le traitement des données est nécessaire
à l'exécution du contrat que j'ai passé
avec toi. Ça, c'est ce que tu as
demandé, l'exécution du contrat.
Ensuite, il y a euh tout ce qui relève
plus ou moins de l'obligatoire.
C'est une obligation légale, une urgence
vitale,
ce genre de trucl. Et donc typiquement
bah quand les pompiers ils sont en train
de te ranimer parce que tu es par terre
à peu près mort dans la rue, ils vont
pas demander ton consentement, ils vont
te ranimer d'abord et on discutera
après.
Et sur le côté légal, tu as par exemple
lorsque tu ouvres un compte bancaire en
ligne où tu traites, voilà, derrière
derrière il y a Trackfin euh Trackfin ou
Trackf qui est un service de
renseignement et qui est là aussi pour
détecter euh d'éventuelles malversations
financières. Donc il y a des il y a des
traitements données qui sont effectués
sur ces
légitimes
qui sont voilà
qui sont obligatoires
qui sont obligatoires et la banque non
mais la banque n'a pas n'a pas d'option
là-dessus, elle doit les mettre en
œuvre. Tuas typiquement ton banquier
quand tu ouvres un compte en banque, il
doit te demander une copie de ta pièce
d'identité. C'est pas parce qu'il a
envie, c'est pas sa procédure à la con,
c'est une obligation. Il doit te
demander une copie d'une pièce
d'identité. Euh donc ça ça fait partie
des cas où c'est obligatoire. Euh
ensuite, il y a un
Pôle Emploi.
Et bien typiquement Pôle Emploi, c'est
l'exécution d'un contrat.
Enfin, c'est servic aussi. Il y a du
service public.
Pô emploi, tu as un contrat avec Pô
Emploi et il exécute ton contrat de
alors je sais plus comment il s'appelle
contrat de retour à l'emploi ou un truc
comme ça. Ça change de nom tout le temps
ce trucl mais c'est bien l'exécution
d'un contrat qu'il y a entre toi et le
prestataire pour l'emploi.
Les réponses à un service public font
font app sont une autre porte qui permet
de justifier le traitement de
Alors j'ai j'ai
et tu as le le le derniers cas qui sont
ce qu'on appelle l'usage légitime
l'intérêt légitime. l'intérêt légitime
où en fait ça c'est
en gros
le traitement qui va être fait
correspond à une chose à laquelle tu
peux légitimement t'attendre de la part
de du prestataire. Typiquement ton
banquier, il surveille le sas d'entrée.
Il y a il y a une vidéo dans le dans le
sas d'entrée pour empêcher les
cambrioleurs et pour empêcher les
braquages. C'est pas l'exécution du
contrat parce que quand tu rentres dans
la banque, tu as pas encore de contrat
avec le banquier mais tu peux
légitimement t'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
des mesures de sécurité assez sévères.
C'est ça qu'on appelle parement parement
en informatique lorsqu'il y a des des
audits qui sont effectuées sur des
traitements enfin sur des comptes
bancaires ou autres euh et sur
l'ensemble dans l'environnement euh par
des solutions logicielles, il y a du
traitement de données personnelles. Bon
ben là ça répond à l'intérêt légitime
parce que le le client s'attend aussi à
ce qu'il y ait des mesures de sécurité
qui soient mises en œuvre par le
responsable de traitement en
l'occurrence la banque. Donc ça ça c'est
le cas particulier de l'intérêt et le
dernier cas c'est si vraiment ça
correspond à rien de tout ça le
traitement ne peut avoir lieu que avec
ton accord. il faut qu'on te demande et
que tu dises explicitement que tu
souhaites que le traitement ait lieu. Et
si tu ne dis rien, c'est que tu n'es pas
d'accord. Et sachant que c'est c'est une
définition juridique du consentement qui
est assez sévère. Typiquement
donc tu as tout un tas de limitations.
Les les mineurs peuvent les mineurs en
dessous d'un certain âge peuvent pas
consentir. Les salariés ne peuvent pas
consentir parce qu'il il constituent un
public vulnérable et donc un traitement
de données qui est fait par le patron
sur les données de ses salariés ne peut
pas être fait sur la base du
consentement. qu'on considère que le
consentement serait vicié.
Donc tu vois le le droit européen dit
ça. Il se trouve que dans la réalité euh
tous les cookies, tous les ciblages
publicitaires et cetera, ils sont basés
sur à peu près n'importe quoi. Tu as
jamais consenti à rien. Moi, je connais
personne sur cette terre qui est
explicitement demandé à recevoir de la
publicité ciblée.
Donc, personne n'a jamais consenti
n'empêche que la publicité ciblée existe
parce que en gros l'ACNIL fait pas son
boulot. Il y a il y a des raisons
historiques pour euh
je veux pas me faire l'avocat de telle
ou telle autorité administrative
indépendante, mais il y a des raisons
historiques. C'est-à-dire que avant le
avant 2018, avant le donc ce fameux
RGPD, le consentement, la règle du
consentement s'appliquait également pour
les les cookies, sauf que le
consentement pouvait être implicite. et
dans la doctrine des autorités de
contrôle, le simple fait par exemple de
rester sur un site et de continuer à
surfer, de scroller et cetera, de de se
balader sur un site sur les rubriques
météo, news, actu, et bien ça signifiait
Ouais, ça devenait un consentement et et
du coup alors c'était très confortable
pour tous les acteurs notamment de la
presse qui ont pour fondement économique
le traitement de données personnelles
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à au-delà du du
enfin c'est jusqu'à l'absolutisme du
traitement de données personnel.
Mais l'arrivée du RGPD a changé la donne
parce que le consentement il n'est plus
implicite, il devient explicite. Donc
pas de case précoché, une information
préalable afin que la personne puisse
savoir en qu'est-ce qui va se passer si
elle coche sur si enfin si elle clique
sur oui ou j'accepte et cetera. Et tout
ça, ça a été une douche écossaise pour
tous ces junky de la donnée personnelle
qui ont dû enfin presque changer de
modèle économique ou en tout cas
s'adapter à ce nouveau climat et ça a
été très douloureux et bon l'acnil a
fait preuve d'un d'une certaine
mensuétude comment on peut appeler ça
d'une grande mensue. Grande mensuétude
c'està-dire qu'elle elle a laissé un
temps d'adaptation c'est-à-dire qu' elle
a pas voulu un coup prè
fallait pas menacer l'emploi
non mais elle a elle a laissé un temps
d'adaptation. Oui oui. Alors c'est c'est
factuellement euh presque vrai. Euh euh
bah c'est que si tu veux le le RGPD, il
a été voté, si ma mémoire est bonne, en
avril 2016 et il est entré en vigueur en
mai 2018. Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y avait
2 ans et 1 mois entre les deux ? Parce
que le Parlement européen savait très
bien que ça allait [__] la grouille
dans pas mal de business model et qu'il
allait falloir que beaucoup de gens
s'adaptent et donc on laissait 2 ans aux
gens pour s'adapter.
2 ans. Bien. L'ACNIL en mai 2018 a rien
fait sur le sujet cookie et Junky de la
data dans le monde de la pub.
Euh de mémoire, ça doit être en
septembre 2019 que on les a traîné
devant le Conseil d'État en référé sur
le fait qu'il faisait rien et du coup
ils sont mis en urgence à revoir leurs
règles sur les cookies et à dire "Mais
si on fait regarder monsieur le conseil
d'État, nous sommes en train de revoir
notre politique sur les cookies." Ça
faisait plus d'un an que leur politique
sur les cookies était illégale à
l'accil. Le document officiel de
l'ACNIL, ils comprenaient rien. C'est
parce que
non mais il sav très bien le document
officiel de l'ACNIL disant comment il
faut faire pour les cookies
publicitaires, ça faisait plus d'un an
qu'il était illégal et ça faisait 3 ans
que le texte sur les données
personnelles était connu parce que le
parlement l'avait voté. Fa
la grille des salaires à l'acil. pas la
moindre idée. Mais tu imagines bien que
les gens de l'ACNIL, le règlement
général sur la protection des données
personnelles, ils l'ont lu. Enfin, c'est
l'accil qui est-ce qui le fournit ?
Ah, il est ridicule. Le budget de
l'accil, il est ridicule. Il est
ridicule. C'est une des autorités
majeures en matière de de numérique et
de données et cetera. Et ils ont un
budget qui est je 100 150 millions
d'euros, même pas. Enfin, c'est
J'ai plus les chiffres en tête,
mais c'est c'est ridicule. Il y a très
très peu de personnes à l'ACNIL. Enfin,
je dirais, je suis pas sûr qu'il y a 200
fonctionnaires en tout, tu vois, pour
contrôler la totalité des entreprises de
France sur le numérique. Ça n'a pas de
sens.
Est-ce que c'est designé ? Est-ce que
c'est fait à des
Laisse-moi terminer sur les cookies,
septembre 2019, de mémoire, il y a ce
moment où on les amène devant le Conseil
d'État. Ils réfléchissent avec toute la
profession, publicité, presse en ligne,
tatata sur comment on va faire, quelles
seront les nouvelles règles et cetera.
Euh, ils accouchent d'un document qui
est publié, je crois, en octobre 2020.
Et dans le document en octobre 2020, ils
disent attention attention au 31 mars
2021, on commence les contrôles. 31 mars
2021 pour un texte qui est sorti du
Parlement en avril 2016. Ça fait 5 ans.
Ça fait 5 ans. Alors effectivement
depuis le 31 mars 2021, on voit quelques
sites de presse où il est presque aussi
facile de refuser les cookies que de les
accepter. C'est que tu as un gros
panneau comme ça qui s'affiche avec un
gros bouton j'accepte en bas et un petit
lien je refuse en haut et l'accil dit ça
c'est conforme.
On est quand même loin de l'esprit du
texte européen qui dit par défaut je
n'accepte pas et ça doit être aussi
facile de refuser que d'accepter. Donc
effectivement l'ACNIL fait preuve de
mensuétude depuis 5 ans mais je n'ai
toujours pas vu d'efforts majeurs et de
sanctions tombé sur les malfaiteurs
notoires. Quand même il
donc c'est plus que de la mensue. 5 ans
ça commence à être autre chose que de la
mensue. Je me fais la voquer du diable.
On voit de plus en plus de sites
internet avec marqué je refuse tout.
Oui en général c'est écrit en petit en
haut de la fenêtre alors que le gros
bouton en bas en couleur jolie il dit
j'accepte. Non, mais alors le Conseil
d'État, ce qu'a expliqué le Conseil
d'État lors des des différents enfin du
référé qui a été lancé, ça a été de dire
que une application, j'allais dire
presque enfin très rigide, très on off,
c'est-à-dire que paf, une décision
couper euh de l'ACNIL au 25 mai à minuit
01, euh bah n'aurait pas été aussi
efficace qu'une approche plus enfin
basée sur l'accompagnement. Donc la CNIL
a opté pour cet accompagnement,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a elle a regroupé
ben je crois que la candidature faisait
partie du collège des des je sais pas
comment on appelait ça, des utilisateurs
avec l'UFC que choisir. Il y avait des
des acteurs de la pub. Donc il y a eu
toutes les discussions qui ont eu qui
ont eu lieu pour justement essayer de
trouver une solution. Donc il y a eu une
démarche après on peut le regretter, le
condamner ou autre mais en tout cas il y
a une démarche d'accompagnement des
différents acteurs euh sur la mise en
place de ces règles qui sont pas
évidentes. D'un point de vue économique,
c'est pas évident. Je alors à à mon tour
de me faire l'avocat du diable, je sais
que migrer comme ça d'un d'un d'une
position de junky de la donnée à quelque
chose qui devient un sevrage euh appuyé
où euh finalement on va demander au
lecteur euh s'il est d'accord ou non
pour être pour voir ces données traites.
Et ben c'est c'est délicat, c'est
difficile.
Alors ça ça je suis parfaitement
d'accord. Mon mon gros problème, c'est
que ce travail là qui a duré en gros un
an et demi hein, entre le moment où
l'acné a dit zut de nos règles sont plus
conforme et le moment où c'est ça s'est
appliqué, il s'est passé à peu près un
an et demi. Moi j'aurais préféré qu'il
commence en avril 2016 et que leur
directive les nouvelles règles soient
édicté tu vois genre mi-27, on dit
attention les nouvelles règles, ce sera
ça et attention parce que en mai en mai
2018 le RGPD rentre en application et
donc le lendemain matin, on peut faire
des contrôles. Donc mettez-vous aux
normes. J'aurais préféré que les 2 ans
de mise aux normees, ce soit les 2 ans
que le législateur avait prévu et non
pas 2 ans, 3 ans, 8 ans, pourquoi pas
35.
En face, en face les acteurs qui
collectent ce type de data, ils disent
quoi ? Ils disent "Laisez-nous du temps,
ça il faut protéger l'emploi."
Bah, il y a il y a de ça. Et puis en
plus et en même temps, c'est ça qui est
qui est assez drôle dans l'histoire,
c'est que ils ont accusé euh les Google
et autres de de gloutonner leur leur
article de presse, leur leur titre de
presse et cetera au point où ces acteurs
ont milité pour l'obtention d'un droit
voisin protégeant leur investissement
industriel. Et euh du coup dans
l'article 15 la directive de droits
d'auteur de 2019 a été reconnu donc un
droit voisin des éditeurs de presse et
qui leur permet justement de réclamer
des sous euh mi
de grosses miettes déjà. Ouais, des
baguettes euh bah sur les épaules de
Google et des autres euh pour euh pour
ses atteintes. Alors à leur euh
je te coupe, on va revenir on va
Tu vois bien qu'il aime quand
il est tout gêné. Il est tout gêné.
Il est il est tout gêné
mais il a l'habitude d'être celui qui
déstabilise les invités et nous on se
laisse pas faire.
un petit couteau. Hop, il est
Non, parce que vous me faites marrer.
Euh, je prends un exemple, on revient à
Pôle Emploi. Pôle Emploi qui se fait
ouvrir, qui se fait poutrer, 1,2 million
de profils de demandeur d'emploi vendu
800 800 ou 825 €
sur certains forums. Qui est responsable
? Celui qui sécurise, Pôle Emploi, celui
qui a rempli la fiche.
Alors,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et on va
continuer sur cette piste là et
extrapoler ce scénario là de fuite de
données.
Alors, tu as tu as plein de en matière
de responsabilité sur les données
personnel, tu as plein de morceaux qui
s'empilent. De base, le responsable,
c'est le responsable du traitement,
c'est-à-dire celui pour qui le
traitement de données existait.
Donc, pour l'emploi,
que le traitement soit réalisé par un
prestataire, un sous-traitant, un
stagiaire, la femme de ménage, euh la
bonne du curé, on s'en fout.
Le le responsable du traitement, c'est
celui pour le compte de qui le
traitement a lieu. Donc dans le cas que
tu décris d'une possible fuite de
données chez Pôle Emploi, le responsable
ce serait Pôle Emploi et ce serait
probablement au final le la puissance
publique. Euh
donc nous
Non, parce qu'en fait le cas
particulier, c'est que la puissance
publique peut pas être condamnée à une
amende
parce que ce serait un peu con que
l'État paye une amende à l'État.
En terme d'écriture comptable, ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens. Euh donc il y a
ça, il y a pas que ça, il y a d'autres
cas. Si tu regardes dans la dans les
annonces sorties dans la presse
aujourd'hui ou, il y a la condamnation
d'IKEA euh pour avoir fait du gros gros
gros caca bien crade avec les données
personnelles des gens. Euh et c'est du
pénal si ma mémoire est bonne. Euh le le
patron a pris 2 ans avec surcis.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Euh en fait,
ils organisaient des systèmes d'enquête
sur leurs salariés en allant piocher des
données aux endroits où ils ont pas le
droit pour euh faire des estimations du
patrimoine, de la vie privée, euh bref,
une surveillance de leur salariés. Donc,
on on est très au-delà, si tu veux, de
du cookie publicitaire. On est quand
même dans du chun,
on est sur du beaucoup plus crade. Euh
mais ça reste dans de la teinte à la vie
privée, si tu veux. Euh donc tu vois de
de la teinte à la vie privée, quand
c'est vraiment un truc très sale, ça
peut aller très au-delà des amendes euh
purement RGPD. Ça peut remonter sur de
la délinquence pénale, des choses comme
ça. Il y a le procès en cours de cet
ancien de la DGSI euh qui utilisait les
accès dont il disposaient au boulot euh
pour vendre des infos euh sur le dark
web. Tous les gens qui voulaient bien en
acheter, que ce soit
ça veut rien dire le dark web. Oui, on
sa nous savons que ça ne veut rien dire,
mais c'est le mot qu'utilisent les juges
dans le dans le procès. Euh donc sur
différents forums et sites de de de
commerce malfamé,
mal référencé et mal fréquenté
et où il trafiquait de la donnée. Alors,
tu imagines quand tu quand tu bosses à
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure, tu as un peu accès à
beaucoup de choses en matière de fichier
et et en gros, il vendait ses accès 50
100000 balles selon le les données qu'on
lui demandait.
Et tu vois ça, ça c'est un peu plus
sérieux et ça ça se passe jusqu'à du
pénal. Enfin, il risque de la prison le
mec. Euh et donc la la question sur
qu'est-ce que tu risques et quelles sont
les sanctions, ça dépend à quel point tu
fais des des saletés. Tu peux risquer de
l'acnil qui fait les gros yeux en
secouant le doigt et en disant c'est pas
bien. On appelle ça une mise en demeure
euh jusqu'à des amendes colossales quand
tu es une entreprise et de la prison si
tu es allé vraiment trop loin. J'ai une
question. Sachant que la mise en
demeure, elle est elle est au-delà le
côté
côté un petit peu caricatural du doigt
en l'air, elle est quand même assez
douloureuse parce que il faut rappeler
aussi que toute activité en ligne est
basée sur un un critère important, c'est
la confiance. Et lorsqu'il y a un doigt
en l'air qui cite nommément une
entreprise,
c'est assez douloureux et ça a un coup.
Et je pense qu'il y a et je crois que
c'était le cas avec Darmanin il y a pas
longtemps, mais je crois qu'il y a il y
a il y a il y a pas mal d'acteurs qui
auraient préféré largement euh être
condamné à à une prune administrative
plutôt qu'à à une simple mise en
demeure. À une mise en demeure parce
qu'un bruit public, euh il faut savoir
comment ça marche l'acnil. C'estàd que
quand publier une mise en demeure
publique, c'est publié au journal
officiel. Il y a un communiqué pour
expliquer correctement euh les rouages
de ces décisions. En bas, il y a la
décision, il y a la délibération et tout
ça c'est envoyé sur l'ensemble des des
réseaux sociaux mais aussi des des
rédactions et pour qui prend la le temps
de lire la délibération. souvent on a
des choses extrêmement graves qui sont
portées. Donc moi, je vous invite
j'invite d'ailleurs tous les
journalistes lorsqu'ils traitent d'une
délibération d'acnil ou une mise en
demeure, même une simple mise en demeur
à à ne lire à ne pas lire le communiqué
de presse quand bien même ne pas lire
tout de suite le communiqué de presse
mais d'abord lire la délibération dans
son intégralité. Alors, c'est sûr que
l'actualité va pas sortir dans les 6
minutes. Bon, mais ça prend un peu plus
de temps, mais on a des éléments
nettement plus concrets et plus et plus
intéressants. Après, sur le le cas le
cas pour l'emploi, il faut il faut aussi
rappeler le changement de de paradigme
qui est consécutif à l'entrée en
application du RGPD, c'est que depuis
l'entrée en vigueur du RGPD, on est
rentré dans une logique de
responsabilité. C'est-à-dire que les
responsables de traitement, hein,
maintenant on a une maturité du enfin en
tout cas théorique, ils sont
responsables du traitement et donc ils
doivent assurer la sécurisation de ces
données de connexion, de ces données de
de pardon ces données
ces données à caractère personnel dès la
conception même de l'ensemble des
systèmes. Et si jamais il y a une faille
de sécurité, c'est pas forcément de la
faute du pirate, du vilain pirate à cœur
qui est venu sur le dark web avec sa
pioche et cetera et cetera
ou pirate tout court. Bref, enfin de la
personne qui fait une atteinte un
traitement automatisé de données, c'est
aussi possiblement la responsabilité du
responsable de traitement que de pas
avoir su correctement anticiper cette
attaque là. Et ça peut ça peut engager
donc une responsabilité de la part de de
cet acteur.
Il faut se faire peine tester de temps
en temps les gars. Question internet.
Que pensent-il du Health Data Hub ?
Ah le Health Data Hub, quel joli sujet !
Euh ça dépas c'est open bar les gars.
Ça dépend sous quel angle euh
sous l'angle. Sous l'angle où vont nos
données ?
Alors il y a il y a
comment c'est centralisé ? Qui ont passé
les marchés ? Qui a gagné de l'argent
autour de ça ?
Alors qui a qui a gagné de l'argent ?
Moi ça ça me gêne ça me gêne pas
forcément.
D'abord je sais pas forcément puis ça me
gêne pas forcément. Euh j'ai des gens
qui desêes artisans qui sont payés à à
artisaner si tu veux ça me gêne pas.
Enfin, tu vois, tout argent gagné n'est
pas forcément soutenable. Euh
ce que c'est que le Data Hub, l'idée
c'est de regrouper sur une plateforme
toutes les données de santé issues de
tout le système médical de la totalité
des Français, enfin la totalité des
habitants de France.
Donc là, on revient à ton explication du
début.
Euh alors il y a il y a de ça, c'estd
que pour le coup euh c'est c'est un
fichier qui concerne absolument tout le
monde dans lequel il y a des données sur
des temps longs, il y a des volumes de
données immenses et qui sont tes
historiques.
C'est que typiquement la radio de quand
tu t'es cassé la clavicule il y a 5 ans
10 ans, elle atterrit là-dedans et elle
va y rester 20 ans 30 ans pour pouvoir
faire du traitement long pour pouvoir
faire des recherches
par analyse de données
sur des cortes très longues et du coup
si tu veux être capable de découvrir un
jour que ah effectivement les gens qui
se cassent la véhicule gauche de telle
façon 27 ans plus tard ont un risque de
développer un problème à la 8e côte
droite, tu vois ? Et ça, tu ne peux le
trouver de manière statistiquement
significative qu'en traitant d'énormes
volume de données sur des périodes très
longues et cetera et cetera et cetera.
Donc le risque euh quand quand je disais
tout fichier est une maltraitance ou une
maltraitance potentielle, le risque
là-dessus est colossal. le risque euh
n'importe quel système d'assurance qui
vient taper là-dedans pour chercher euh
est-ce que tu aurais pas des fois euh eu
des problèmes cardiaque il y a 15 ans et
donc on peut pas te prêter de pognon
pour acheter ta bagnole ou ta voiture ?
C'est le le risque est colossal.
Euh
il se trouve que le Data Hub a été sous
les feux de l'actualité parce que ils
ont choisi comme prestataires pour
héberger leurs solutions euh Microsoft
Azure sur des serveurs ultra sécurisés
sur tout est géré en Europe, ils ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts sur le
chiffrement et cetera et cetera et
cetera
mais il se trouve que Microsoft est une
entreprise de droit américaine qui est
donc soumise au Cloud Act et au Patriote
Act euh et que donc on n'est pas sûr que
cet hébergement soit tout à fait
conforme à la jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice de l'Union européenne. Donc
d'un point de vue juridique, pour le
moment en référé, le Conseil d'État a
dit "Bon, ça va parce que en fait il
sait pas quoi dire d'autre parce que il
y a pas il y a pas tellement de
prestataires sur lesquels le DATUB
pourrait comme ça du jour au lendemain
transférer les données."
Donc pour le moment en référé, le
Conseil d'État a répondu "Ouais, il y a
quand même pas mal de de précautions
prises, mettons."
Mais ça va pas beaucoup plus loin que ça
sa décision et il y aura forcément une
décision sur le fond puisque une
procédure en référé est toujours double
l'engagement de Cédric que deigrer.
Voilà. Et donc derrière, il y a eu un
engagement politique de Cédric Ha et
puis derrière des gens du Health Data
Hub qui qui rochignait un petit peu à
migrer tout ça sur une solution qui soit
du claude souverain aussitôt que ce sera
possible.
Euh sinon donc ça c'est le volet RGPD
conformité droit européen. Après il y a
ce que je pense moi de le Data Hub. Euh
l'hypercentralisation des données,
j'aime pas. Euh je comprends l'intérêt,
il y a un intérêt pour la recherche qui
est réel.
Euh il y a cependant un risque. L'outil
est tellement dangereux, il y a
tellement de données de tellement de
gens avec
alors je dirais pas pas de cadre parce
que c'est pas vrai, mais je ne sais pas
s'il y a assez de cadre. Et donc je j'ai
spontanément
euh une réticence.
Euh le fait que on collecte les données
de la totalité de la population sans
demander la vie de personne euh sur le
principe je n'aime pas ça qu'on invite
la totalité de la population à mettre à
disposition euh
je développe ça autrement. Les données
de santé aujourd'hui, elles sont
centrées sur le médecin.
Mon pneumologue a des données sur moi,
mon généraliste a des données sur moi,
mon cardiologue a des données sur moi,
monologue,
mon mon mon pédicure a des données sur
moi. Enfin, chacun des traitants a des
données sur moi. Et moi, j'ai pas la
main sur ces dossiers. J'aimerais mieux
un système qui soit centré sur le
patient où mes données de santé sont
sous mon contrôle et j'ouvre un accès à
ceux des médecins qui me soignent.
Et donc il y a le même problème qu'avec
le gars de la DG si
mes données de santé sont sous mon
contrôle et j'ouvre où je révoque
l'accès au médecin qui me soigne et où
du coup qu'on vienne ensuite me demander
est-ce que je souhaite que mes données
soient versées au fond pour la recherche
? Oui, non, ça m'irait très bien. Et
puis il y aurait peut-être
éventuellement que ce soit activé par
défaut et que je puisse le désactiver ou
mais tu vois l'idée que c'est moi ces
données. Ces données, c'est moi, c'est
ma santé, ça décrit mon corps, ça décrit
qui je suis, ça ça décrit de quoi j'ai
souffert au cours du temps,
physiquement ou mentalement, puisque
bien évidemment toutes les données de
mine de médecine psychiatrique vont être
avec.
ces données, c'est moi. L'ensemble de
ces données, c'est moi. Et moi ça me ça
m'embête que je n'ai plus la main
dessus.
Comment ça se mélange avec le secret
médical, tout ça ?
Alors, il faut comprendre ce que c'est
que le secret médical. Le secret médical
est un secret qui lit le médecin et le
patient
et en particulier que l'immense majorité
des en fait quelqu'un qui n'a pas à en
connaître ne peut pas poser la question.
C'est ce qui fait que quand je suis en
arrêt maladie, je n'ai aucune obligation
de dire à mon patron de quoi je suis
malade. Euh c'est ce qui fait que si je
dis à mon médecin euh généraliste ou
psychiatre que j'ai des envies de
suicide, il n'a pas à le dire à
personne. Et à quoi sert le secret
médical ? À ce que je puisse dire la
vérité à mon médecin ? À ce que je
puisse lui faire confiance ? À ce que je
puisse lui dire euh j'ai la [__] qui me
gratte. Tu vois le truc que tu dirais
pas à ton voisin ou euh que
tu le connais beaucoup
ou ou alors tu es très intime avec tes
voisins. C'est Mais tu vois, il y a il y
a un truc que je t'embrasse.
Tu tu peux tu peux dire euh tu dois
pouvoir dire à ton médecin ce que tu ne
confierais pas euh à ton voisin, au
juge, au policier, à la crémière, tu
vois. Et c'est à ça que sert le secret
médical pour que tu puisses vraiment
dire les choses à ton médecin et qu'il
sache
que quand il te demande "Est-ce que tu
as encore mal à tel endroit, est-ce que
tu as encore tel problème ? Est-ce que
tu boîes encore ? Toi, tu voudrais pas
que ton patron le sache parce qu'il il
va vouloir il va vouloir te virer mais
il faut que ton médecin puisse le
savoir. Et donc ça sert à ça le secret
médical, c'est pas un secret absolu.
Et donc typiquement euh quand on verse
un dossier et qu'il est traité de
manière anonyme par des chercheurs, il y
a pas d'atteinte au secret médical. euh
les les chercheurs qui font un travail
sur des dossiers, même si les dossiers
sont encore nominatifs quand ils sont
dans les dans les bases de données ou
encore rattaché à des identifiants. S'il
est rattaché à ton numéro de SQ, il y a
pas ton nom, enfin c'est toi. Euh
les les analyses que vont faire les
chercheurs portent pas sur ton nom, ils
s'en foutent, eux ils analysent des
cortes.
Tu vois rien que le moindre test médical
de de test sur un vaccin ou de choses
comme ça comme on fait ou
non le test de l'épistage il est
nominatif pour qu'on te dise à toi si tu
es malade mais siôt que tu l'agrèges
pour faire des stats et pour faire des
analyses de cortes on s'en fout de
savoir si c'est Pierre Paul ou Jacques.
On regarde des nombres. Donc le ça ça
c'est pas une atteinte au secret
médical. En revanche, le fait qu'on
utilise tes données personnelles sans
ton sans ton consentement, c'est une
atteinte à ta personne. Et est-ce que
l'intérêt
l'intérêt général que représente la
recherche médicale est suffisant pour
justifier une atteinte généralité
généralisée aux données personnelles de
la totalité de la population de France ?
Donc je rebondis, je rebondis. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du pass sanitaire et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des futures
dispositions que sont en train de nous
concocter nos sénateurs pour endiguer
les futures pandémies qui consisterait à
surveiller ton activité commerciale ?
C'est-à-dire si tu achètes des choses
pour te soigner, ça pourrait indiquer
que tu es malade. Donc on pourrait te
mettre sous surveillance. Le fait qu'on
puisse te mettre un petit bracelet
électronique pour te tracer, le fait
qu'on bloque tes comptes bancaires ou
ton pass navigo ou des petitte choses
comme ça. Le pass sanitaire pour vous ça
vous fait penser à quoi ? C'est un éème
truc numérique qui est remplacé pour
pomper encore plus de data. Est-ce qu'on
aurait pas pu remplacer ça avec un
carnet de santé à l'ancienne comme on
allait se balader en Afrique avec notre
certificat de vaccination pour les
maladies tropicales ou est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui a un grand intérêt ?
Déjà, la loi sur la la fin de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prépa que le pas
sanitaire peut-être sous forme
électronique mais également papier. Donc
ton bon vieux carnet de santé tout jauni
là qui traîne au fin fond d'un tiroir
jaune c'est vrai hein.
Ben oui, je je le sais, je le sais. Tu
es mon voisin. Euh
mais tu t'appelles pas Patrick ?
Non. Et ça me gratte pas.
Truc avec d'autres voisins.
Ben je sais, je sais, je sais. Tu
es jaloux.
Pas trop. Très bien.
Euh donc la loi en question, elle elle
autorise un pass sanitaire qui vient
donc euh soit donner indication ton état
de santé au regard du du vaccin, enfin
ton état au regard du vaccin, soit euh
expliquer que tu as été atteint atteint
ou atteinte par ce fichi ce fichi machin
qui le covid et que bah aujourd'hui
c'est un mieux. Soit que tu as fait un
test dans les 72 heures préalables et
que celui-ci se révèle négatif.
Donc il peut être en version papier ou
en version électronique. Donc
alors il y a plein de choses sur le
principe. Euh
je suis très favorable à une obligation
du vaccin.
J'ai a toute une corte de vaccins qui
sont obligatoires en France pour des
raisons de santé publique. Je suis tout
à fait favorable à ce que celui-là de
vaccin soit obligatoire comme les autres
parce que il est en train de poser un
[__] de problème majeur qui n'est plus
que de la santé publique. Bah, tu es en
train de faire comme ça parce que c'est
du pognon, je suis pas d'accord. Ça
détruit des gens, ça fait du mal aux
gens, ça les rend fou de rester enfermé,
de plus avoir de vie sociale. Enfin,
c'est c'est en train de tuer les gens
petit à petit. Euh et donc voilà, je moi
je suis plutôt favorable à une
obligation euh une forme d'obligation
vaccinale. Euh en revanche, je comprends
pas bien pourquoi on couplerait ça à du
contrôle policier et à du contrôle
d'identité. Je veux dire, il y a tout un
tas de vaccins obligatoires et
jamais nulle part un patron de barre ne
m'a demandé de présenter mes certificats
de vaccination. Jamais.
Euh et il a jamais couplé la le contrôle
de quand on vérifie tes vaccins pour que
tu ailles dans tel pays où il y a la la
fèvre jaune, la dingue que sais-je et où
tu dois te vacciner contre la malaria,
la diftérie, enfin tout ce qu'on peut.
Un
vaccin pour la malaria.
Pardon, je suis pas assez spécialiste en
maladie exotique et tropicale mais le
les endroits où on va contrôler ça, ça
va être au moment où tu embarques dans
l'avion. C'est hyper limité. C'est pas
un patron de bois de barre qui vérifie
au moment où tu rentres pour boire une
bière et c'est pas nécessairement couplé
avec un contrôle de ton identité.
Le passe sanitaire euh dans sa forme
électronique et dans sa forme papier à
celle avec un QR code et cetera embarque
trop d'informations et il embarque des
informations qui n'ont rien à faire là
et il permet
au moindre patron de boîte de nuit,
patron de barre, patron de salle de
concert de collecter sur la totalité des
des gens présents des informations
beaucoup trop fortes euh d'accéder à ces
informations et de les conserver s'il a
envie. Et ça c'est un problème, ça c'est
embêtant et c'est d'autant plus embêtant
euh derrière indépendamment de cette
question là qui est pour moi une
question de de de principe et de ce que
j'en pense, il y a ce que dit la loi. Il
y a eu un petit clash parlementaire
autour de de ce pass sanitaire. Je sais
pas si si tu t'en souviens mais quand
quand le texte de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a été voté au
Parlement, le groupe Modem qui fait
partie de la majorité a dit "Nous, on
veut pas le voter en l'État parce que il
y a ça et ça sur le passe sanitaire et
ça nous va pas et on veut un passe
sanitaire plus light et on veut en
particulier retirer telles et telles
infos." Etth et le gouvernement a cédé.
Euh et donc après une petite
demi-journée de de microcrise si tu veux
euh le texte de loi a été modifié. et le
pass sanitaire a été adopté dans une
version un peu plus stricte en matière
de protection des données personnelles.
Or, ce que le gouvernement euh applique
en ce moment, c'est ce qu'il avait
prévu. C'est pas ce que le parlement a
voté. Et alors, si tu veux, le côté
l'exécutif écrit la loi puis commence à
l'appliquer alors qu'il l'a pas encore
présenté au législatif. Le législatif
dit qu'il est pas d'accord, modifie la
loi et l'exécutif s'entonne le
coquillard. Moi ça me pose un problème
d'état de droit indépendamment de la
question sanitaire donnée personnelle
tralala tralala ça me pose un problème
d'état de droit
et c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un référé
parce que ça ça ne va pas. Bah parce que
vendredi on sera on saura euh justement
au Conseil d'État, il y a une audience
qui à 10h je crois si à 10h ce vendredi.
Conseil d'État dira si le textes ou les
pratiques d'application de de cette loi
sont en conformité justement avec ce
texte législatif et
s'il y a disensus et ben normalement il
pourra sabrer.
Il devra sabrer. Il devrait mais d'un
autre côté le conseil d'État c'est
toujours très compliqué parce qu'il te
dit si c'est manifestement illégal si en
fait il faut que ce soit un éléphant au
milieu de la pièce
il coupe
si ça n'est que un petit peu illégal il
laisse.
J'ai j'ai le même problème avec la copie
privée
et on a le même problème sur la copie
privée. C'est c'est une constante et tu
vois le le
je ne sais pas si le Conseil d'État aura
le courage de dire au gouvernement qu'il
est en train de ne pas respecter la loi
qu'il a fait voter et sur laquelle il
avait obtenu un accord politique qui
n'était pas un accord évident. C'était
pas la majorité votant le petit loi sur
la couture du pantalon. Ça avait faitus
à l'assemblée et ça avait créé un petit
fight. Si tu veux pour faire monter des
gens du modem au fight, on n'est pas
dans les radicaux en politique, tu vois.
On n'est pas dans les durs. Les
les gens du modem, ils commencent à se
fighter quand ils arrêtent de manger.
Quand ils sont bien affamés, ça les
énerve et là ils montent là. Bon, trêve
de plaisanterie. Question internet.
Comment expliquer que l'armée française
utilise encore Windows 7 que il y a 5
jours, un mot de passe utilisé lors de
l'exercice d'un étatmajor a été
involontairement publié sur Twitter et
je rajoute sur leur site internet qu'on
ait choisi Google et Microsoft pour
protéger les données dans le cloud pour
les services de l'État. que des
militaires se font tracer sur les
réseaux sociaux, que la Roumanie ou
l'Estonie a un écosystème tech digne de
ce nom. Est-ce que franchement on n'est
pas dans un pays du tiers monde
technologique et qu'on n pas déjà perdu
la guerre ?
Question de polaire. Alors euh je peux
te faire un bout de réponse en en terme
de de politique économique.
Euh on n'est pas du tier monde du du
numérique, c'est pas vrai. Il y a en
France des armées d'ingénieurs tout à
fait qualifiés, des tas d'entreprises
capables de faire et cetera. paye pas
qu' se tir aux États-Unis parce qu'ils
sont mieux payés,
qu'on paye pas si mal que ça. Les vrais
techniciens pour le coup, on on paye
assez bien les les chefs de projet, les
consultants euh et cetera et les les
techniciens hardcore, on les paye moins
bien qu'un certain nombre d'entreprises,
mais parce que en fait, il y a pas de il
y a pas de politique économique sur le
numérique en France. Euh moi, ce qui m'a
frappé dans les annonces du 17 mai
autour du cloud souverain par Bruno
Lemè,
euh c'est qu'il a fait une
Il a pasonné un peu ? Non non, il a fait
une annonce de DSI, il a pas il a pas
fait une annonce de ministre.
il a dit il a dit bah je vois bien que
euh que la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne dit que héberger chez les
cloud providers américains,
c'est pas conforme. Du coup, bah
l'administration va arrêter mais d'un
autre côté, il y a pas un seul acteur
économique européen qui soit à peu près
au bon niveau de service. Donc je vais
attendre que les grands providers
américains fournissent leurs solutions
logicielles sous licence à des acteurs
économique européens
pour queon puisse utiliser leurs
services sur des acteurs économiques
européens. C'est une décision de DSI,
c'est une décision de directeur des
systèmes d'information qui dit "Bon
effectivement, il y a un problème
juridique, la bonne solution c'est que
plutôt que de mettre ça chez Microsoft,
je vais acheter une licence Microsoft
via Orange et Cap Gémini. Euh et puis ça
va marcher. Effectivement, ça résout le
problème de droit parce que c'est plus
une entreprise qui est soumise à du
droit américain. Tu as créé une
indirection. Donc en terme de DSI, il a
résolu son problème juridique. En
revanche, il a pas du tout défini une
stratégie économique pour le pays. Il a
défini rien du tout. Je veux dire, on
est une dépendance
économique
de de des Américains, des Chinois, des
Taiwanais, des Japonais en matière
d'électronique grand public, en matière
d'informatique. Il n'a pas défini une
stratégie. Et ça ça me pose problème.
Euh si tu veux que le DSI de l'État
prenne une décision de DSI, ça m'irait
très bien, mais d'un ministre, j'attends
une décision de ministre, c'est-à-dire
une politique économique.
Fier d'être des amateurs qui l'avait
dit, non ? Ouais, c'est ça. Soyez fier
d'être des branleurs.
Mais si tu veux, moi ça me pose
problème. J'attends une stratégie
économique. J'attends qu'il m'explique
comment on fait pour que les entreprises
françaises et européennes qui bossent
dans ce secteur là et qui sont pas si
mauvaises que ça puissent monter en
puissance. Quelles est la garantie de la
commande publique ? Parce que là, ce
qu'il vient d'expliquer, c'est que la
commande publique serait garantie à aux
gens qui achètent des licences chez
Microsoft et chez Google, pas aux gens
qui produisent du logiciel. Comment tu
protèges les éditeurs logiciel européens
? comment tu permets l'existence d'un
écosystème par exemple autour du
logiciel libre enfin tuis comment tu
définis une stratégie économique comment
tu dis économiquement je vais fabriquer
un écosystème d'entreprises qui
travaillent ensemble et qui sont
capables de de rendre le service
numérique dont on a besoin ça ça me pose
un problème.
Il a pas lu le petit bouquin tu sais là
d'état pour les nuls.
Je sais pas s'il existe celui-là.
On va s'y mettre. On va lui on va lui
écrire Marc, tu veux tu veux rebondir
là-dessus ou est-ce que tu veux que je
t'envoie sur un autre sujet ?
Ouais, sur un autre sujet.
Alors, enfin parce que complétude
absolue. Donc un autre sujet. Ouais.
La copie privée.
Oui.
La copie privée, c'est quoi ? C'est un
effet de manche. Est-ce que c'est pour
payer la transition écologique, payer
les droits d'auteur ? Est-ce que les
auteurs sont les crèves la dalle ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui parasitent
les auteurs ? Est-ce que ça sert à
quelque chose ? Est-ce que ça va pas
être contre-productif ? Est-ce que Alors
déjà, c'est quoi la copie privée ?
Ah, c'est une taxe.
Une taxe, c'est ça ?
Non, c'est pas une taxe. Et je vous je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Ça ressemble beaucoup quand même.
Alors, la copie privée, alors c'est un
sujet que je suis depuis depuis 16 ans.
16 ans l'air de déprimer comme ça là.
Euh parce que j'ai pendant longtemps,
j'ai été seul à à le suivre ou trop seul
en tout cas. Euh,
tu as des chats ?
J'ai un chat, ouais. Euh, et pendant
longtemps, je l'ai j'ai j'étais un petit
peu seul à le suivre
et et le chat et la copie privée. La
copie privée, c'est quoi ? En fait,
c'est une c'est une institution qui est
née il y a bien longtemps en 1957 et qui
a été consacrée aussi par la la grande
loi de 1985 et qu'on retrouve maintenant
dans une directive de 2001 sur le droit
d'auteur.
Et la redevance copie privée qui n'est
pas une taxe
est une institution qui est là et en
fait une indemnité qui est là qui est
versée au à ces victimes qui que sont
les sociétés de gestion collective et
d'ailleurs leur sociétair et qui vient
compenser
exemple c'est quoi les sociétés en
question là
comme la SASM, la SCD, la Dami, l'Aspedy
Dame et cetera et cetera.
la SCAM évidemment
et euh qui est qui est perçu pour
compenser un préjudice he je un
préjudice qui est la liberté qui est
reconnue à chacun de réaliser des
copies. Alors pour comprendre cela, il
faut revenir un tout petit peu en avant.
Euh en matière de propriété
intellectuelle, lorsque un auteur crée
hein
le point sur le front et cetera et qu'il
va créer une œuvre et bien il a un
monopole sur cette œuvre. Et toi euh ben
si tu veux copier cette œuvre-là
en format numérique ou pas, peu importe,
tu dois lui demander l'autorisation
préalable hein, savoir s'il est d'accord
ou pas. Évidemment, c'est pas possible à
l'échelle d'un pays que l'ensemble des
personnes contacte l'ensemble des
auteurs pour réclamer la possibilité de
savoir s'ils peuvent faire une
compilation pour la pour le CD de la la
Renault 5. Euh et euh
et bien face à cette impossibilité de
demander l'autorisation de réaliser des
copies et a été institué donc cette
redevance, cette indemnité pour copies
privée qui vient donc compenser cette
liberté qui é accordée de réaliser à
titre personnel hein des copies privées.
Voilà. sur le papier. Moi je trouve ça
plutôt sympathique. Je trouve ça je ser
plutôt je trouve ça plutôt sympathique.
Et on voit déjà que c'est pas une taxe
parce que c'est une indemnité. Elle
vient compenser un préjudice. Elle a
plutôt une nature on est plus proche du
dommage intérêt.
Compensatoire.
Ouais une compensation. Alors taxe,
j'aime pas le mot taxe déjà parce que
juridiquement c'est faux
mais aussi parce que et je je l'ai déjà
dit je crois un peu à droite à gauche
c'est que c'est quasiment diffamatoire
pour la fiscalité. C'est diffamatoire
pour la fiscalité parce que la fiscalité
lorsqu'on a un nouvel impôt qui est mise
en œuvre et bien l'impôt il va être
débattu par des personnes très
compétentes que sont les députés et
sénateurs. On va avoir des commissions
parlementaires.
Je je finis je finis.
C'est de l'ironie là ou quoi ? un petit
peu mais non mais c'est c'est vrai non
non réellement la fiscalité la fiscalité
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas simple du
qui est pas simple mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que lorsque les
sénateurs et députés bossent et
planchent sur des nouvelles normes
fiscales et bien il y a tout un travail
parlementaire qui est fait il y a des
rapports, il y a des examens en
commission, il y a des amendements. Euh
ça s'agite,
ça s'agite et ça justifie son salaire.
Il y a des camion peu importe peu
importe ça. Ce que je veux dire par là,
ce qui m'intéresse le plus la
transparence. C'està-dire que lorsqu'il
y a des débats qui ont lieu comme ça sur
sur des euh pour pour créer ou moduler
un impôt existant, euh il y a des
caméras, il y a des micros, il y a des
rapports, il y a des des auditions et
cetera. Et donc la personne qui veut
savoir, la personne qui est qui sait qui
qui a des bases en fiscalité ou qui veut
essayer de comprendre, qui veut se
donner la peine de comprendre, elle a
accès à tout ça. La redevance copie
privée, c'est un tout petit peu
différent. Alors cette indemnité, elle
est fixée par une commission
administrative, donc déjà c'est dire si
elle est importante, qui est rattachée
au ministère de la culture physiquement
et qui est composé de 12 redevables et
12 bénéficiaires. Les 12 12
bénéficiaires, ce sont nos amis des
ayants droit, donc la SSM, la SCD, la
DAMI, la SCAM, l'ASPDAM, la SCAM à
chaque fois. Bonjour Hervéronie.
Euh et euh donc là on a le collège des
des bénéficiaires. Bénéficiaires,
c'est-à-dire que c'est eux qui vont
percevoir cette redevance via leur
société, une société civile qui
s'appelle Copyifance. Et en face en face
on a 12 non pas bénéficiaires mais
redevables. Et ces 12 redevables et là
c'est c'est assez curieux c'est que
cette commission dite paritaire
paritaire il y a une idée de d'équilibre
c'est ces 12 sièges sont coupés en deux
en fait. Donc tu n'as pas 12 personnes
du même ADN, tu as 12, tu as six
consommateurs
et six représentants des fabricants.
Et tu peux enfin,
je sais pas si fait très longues études,
mais on quiconque peut comprendre que
une assosce de consommateur va pas
forcément partager les mêmes vues que
qu'un fabricant comme Samsung. comme
Samsung parce que bah c'est ils ont deux
ADN différents et il parlent pas la même
langue. Donc déjà on voit que bah on a
12, c'est pas 12 contre 12, c'est 12 6
et là il y a il y a un bon principe qui
marche depuis des années, c'est diviser
pour mign
ça c'est ton interprétation ?
C'est mon interprétation et qui est tiré
aussi des d'un constat des faits.
C'està-dire que ben les a droit sont
dans leur dans leur dans leur aquarium.
C'est-à-dire que ce sont eux qui sont en
force au sein de cette commission.
Pourquoi ? Parce que il leur suffit
d'une voie du compte d'en face pour euh
faire valoir leur position. Alors que
les six consommateurs, s'ils obtiennent
une voie du compte en face, que ce soit
des fabricants ou des aillants en droit,
et ben il 6 s passe à 7
et ça marche pas, c'est pas suffisant.
Ajoutons à cela que le président de la
commission copie privée Jean Musistelli
qui était autrefois il y a très
longtemps le président de la RMT tu te
rappelles l'autorité de régulation des
mesures techniques de protection
pauvre tal non
comment euh bah il il n'hésite pas à
voter aussi à participer au vote et bah
en faveur des aandroits. Donc là encore
récemment il a voté en faveur des aans
droit.
C'est bien non ?
Ah oui c'est très bien c'est très bien
c'est très bien. Donc on a on a on a
cette commission. Alors, dans cette
commission, il y a pas de micro euh en
fait, il y a pas de caméra qui filme en
direct, il y a pas de micro qui qui
enregistre en direct. Donc, on n' pas
accès aux débats. Les débats, on on y'y
a accès que par la suite, plusieurs
semaines plus tard, lorsque des
compte-rendus dit synthétiques sont
publiés. Comme l' du CNC, c'est ça ?
Je je non je parle de la copie privée et
euh et donc ce régime là, il est il est
un petit peu curieux parce que c'est
très difficile pour une personne déjà de
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
ficelles de de cette cette entité et
surtout d'avoir accès aux données.
L'accès aux données est très compliqué.
Donc là récemment
la commission copie privée, en tout cas
copie France plutôt a mené a mené à bien
un drôle de combat, c'est que en 2000,
ils ont décidé de traîner devant les
tribunaux bah des petites PME
qui font du reconditionné.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle considère que
ces produits reconditionnés, notamment
téléphone et tablettes, doivent faire
l'objet d'un prélèvement de copie
privée, hein, qui peut monter en crête.
selon le barê en question jusqu'à 14 €.
14 € hein, c'est pas neutre pour un
téléphone.
Ils vont faire quoi de cet argent ?
Alors cet argent bah après on peut je
peux revenir là-dessus mais cet argent
donc est collecté euh par Copie France.
Euh alors j'avais obtenu les chiffres
2020 ils ont ils ont glané 273 millions
d'euros 273 millions d'euros grâce à
cette redevance qui est basée sur la
copie. Alors, c'est assez formidable
parce que en commission copie privée
pour établir les barêes et l'assiette,
l'assiette, c'est-à-dire sur quels sont
les supports qui vont être frappés et
les barê ou les taux euh à quel à quelle
force, à quel à quel montant, euh ben la
la commission copie privée met euh en
route des études d'usage. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils prennent un panel, ils mettent un
thermomètre dans le panel, on leur
demande quelles sont les pratiques de
copie qu'il réalisent et en fonction des
chiffres, on met tout ça dans une espèce
de de grosse marmite, hein, on remue et
puis on a on a 14 € pour un téléphone de
plus 64 Go. Et très curieusement, ce
sont les endroits qui financent ces
études d'usage hein, au sein d'une
commission où ils ont 12 sièges, il leur
manque qu'une voie pour obtenir la
majorité absolue, hein. et le tout pour
pour déterminer ensuite
une redevance qu'ils vont eux-mêmes
percevoir
et qu'ils vont ensuite se partager. Et
qui c'est qui contrôle tout ça ?
Alors, qui c'est qui contrôle tout ça ?
Bon, déjà, il y a le maître de cérémonie
Jean Musitéelli, en tout cas le
président de la commission de protection
des droits,
le président de la commission copie
privée qui est là pour pour assurer le
profond respect du règlement intérieur.
Est
tout seul. Euh alors derrière on a aussi
la commission de contrôle des sociétés
de gestion collective ou des organismes
de gestion collective comment ils
appellent maintenant euh qui est là pour
vérifier si tout est fait
dans les dans Ouais dans les règles de
l'art comptable en tout cas. Et on a
aussi les parlementaires. Et là
récemment Éric Botorel euh a prononcé
des gros mots, vraiment des gros mots,
puisque il a demandé à ce que au détour
d'un amendement sur un projet de loi euh
relatif à l'environnement et au
numérique, il a demandé à ce que des euh
bah une mission, un rapport soient mené
pour essayer de comprendre un petit peu
les rouages, savoir comment aujourd'hui
on arrive à percevoir encore 273
millions d'euros alors qu'on est passé
d'une logique de de stock, hein. On se
rappelle tous dans les années 90 2000 et
cetera, colonne de CD qu'on empilait
soigneusement, on s'imprimait les
pochettes et cetera avec des œuvres
évidemment copié légalement
et copier légalement.
Légalement légalement.
Non, parce que attention, tu as quand
même un truc, la redevance copie privée,
elle est assise sur le fait que tu as le
droit de copier.
le
le le
la cassette que tu fais avec ton ton mix
tape préféré pour écouter dans la
voiture ou dans ton walkman depuis que
tu es ado, tu as le droit. Tu as le
droit de faire ça.
Le fait d'emprunter l'album bidule à ton
pote et d'en copier la chanson que tu
veux dans ta mix tape et ensuite de
rendre son album à ton pote, tu as le
droit et tu as le droit depuis très
longtemps et tu as toujours le droit.
Donc aujourd'hui, tu récupères un
morceau de musique chez ton pote, tu le
tu le copies sur ton téléphone, ton
baladeur, ta mixtape, machin, tu as le
droit. Cette liberté de faire une copie
par que Marc a raison de me reprendre.
Euh c'est ça la contrepartie de la copie
privée.
C'est c'est un contrat un contrat une
espèce de donnant donnant.
Donnant, c'est-à-dire que effectivement
sur l'ensemble des supports euh
c'estàdire tous les supports euh est
prélevé une redevance copie privée, mais
en contrepartie, tu te vois accorder la
liberté que de réaliser ces ces copies
sans demander l'autorisation euh bah au
créateur. Mais après, il y a des
particularismes qui sont qui sont
magnifiques.
La logique voudrait que alors je te dis
que c'est une directive de 2001 qui
encadre ce ce régime aujourd'hui, mais
la logique voudrait que la redevance
copie privée qui s'applique
et qui concerne donc les usages
particuliers des personnes physiques,
bah ne concernne pas les entreprises.
C'estàd qu'une entreprise n'a pas payé
la copie privée,
hein. Et donc très logiquement, il
faudrait que la copie privée soit
prélevée, bah par exemple entre le
distributeur et le consommateur. Donc
lorsque tu vas à la Fnac ou sur rue du
commerce ou sur Amazon, n'importe où,
voilà, en tant que particulier qui va
acheter des supports vierge et puis là
on te facture la redevance copie privée,
ensuite que l'argent aille directement
dans les poches de Copie France.
Copie France donne
et après Copie France les réparti entre
les sociétés de gestion collective et
qu'il est réparti ensuite en fonction
des enfin selon les artistes artistes
euh compositeurs, producteurs et cetera
et cetera. Mais je rev si je traduis ça
en en exemple juste pour euh
quand j'achète un DVD vierge pour copier
le le Seigneur des Anneaux, je paye une
redevance copie privée. Quand mon
laboratoire d'imagerie médicale achète
des DVD vierges pour mettre ton scanner,
ton IRM dessus, il paye une redevance
copie privée alors qu'ils font jamais de
copie privée. C'est
c'est là je voulais en venir. Donc la
logique voudrait que la la redovance
soit prélevée entre le distributeur et
le consommateur final à charge pour le
le distributeur de vérifier toi
consommateur qui vient me voir est-ce
que tu as un laboratoire d'analyse
médicale ou est-ce que tu es monsieur ou
madame Jean-Kevin Michu
marche pas comme ça en France non en
France on a choisi un autre système
enfin les endroits ont pensé à un autre
système qui qui est assez efficace je
trouve en terme en terme de rendement
c'est de prélever la redonance copie
privée non pas chez le distributeur mais
chez l'importateur et en sortie de PBO
Lorsque concrètement tu as des palettes
de de de disque dur externe de de
tablettes de téléphones et cetera qui
sont vomis comme ça sur sur le
territoire français et bien voilà si
j'apporte x millions de ou x centaines
de de milliers de de téléphones ou
autres et ben je multiplie ça par 14 €
s'ils font plus de 64 Go et puis après
je verse ça à Copie France. Mais après,
on sent assez facilement la nuance,
c'est que l'importateur, lui, il sait
pas si le consommateur final, enfin
l'acheteur final de ces produits-là, ça
va être monsieur et madame Jean- Kevin
Michu ou alors le laboratoire d'analyse
médicale dans d'en bas ou le cabinet
d'avocat ou le cabinet de comptable ou
le garagiste ou le notaire ou euh
l'église ou l'association et cetera et
cetera. Donc les les les l'infinité de
cet argent cet argent il est fait pour
faire quoi cet argent prélevé ? Alors
cet argent, il est euh comme je te l'ai
dit, il est là pour pour compenser un
préjudice. C'est pour ça que j'aime pas
le mot taxe parce que c'est une insulte
qui est faite à la fiscalité, au regard
de la transparence et j'aime surtout pas
le mot rémunération qui est employé dans
le code de la propriété intellectuelle
parce que quand on parle de rémunération
pour copie privée, euh le gars derrière
son clavier, derrière sa guitare,
derrière son micro ou autre, bah il voit
une ligne avec marqué rémunération pour
copie privée. Pour lui, c'est une nature
quasiment enfin c'est quasiment un
salaire. Il y a une nature comme ça
comme ça alimentaire d'a rémunération et
on touche pas à mes rémunérations. Qui
tu es enfin qui es-tu toi pour toucher à
mes rémunérations ? H et donc c'est déjà
on a une guerre des mots là-dessus alors
qu'en réalité c'est pas une
rémunération, c'est une compensation,
c'est une indemnité hein. Et cet argent
il est là pour compenser donc cette
liberté. Sachant qu'il y a aussi une un
particularisme notamment en France,
c'est que une partie de 273 millions
d'euros, on en est à 270 300 millions
d'euros chaque année qui sont prélevés
maintenant avec la redevance copie
privée. Une partie de ces ces ces 300
millions d'euros et bien est conservée
par les sociétés de gestion collective,
c'est 25 % pour financer notamment les
actions culturelles, les festivals mais
également les actions de lobbying. C'est
prévu, c'est fléché dans le code de la
propriété intellectuelle hein. prévu.
Donc euh ils doivent garder 25 % de 300
300 millions pour financer les festivals
ou autres. Et je me rappelle d'ailleurs
il y a quelques années, j'étais j'étais
au j'étais aux rencontres
cinématographiques de de Dijon et
Jean-Noël Tron qui est le numéro 1 de la
SASM avait dit micro en main et je j'ai
filmé donc on trouve la vidéo très
facilement. il avait dit que grâce à ces
25 % de la copie privée euh ils avaient
un instrument un instrument de de de
solidarité hein ou peut-être d'influence
en tout cas un un levier important un
levier important avec les élus avec les
élus pourquoi parce que lorsque
est-ce que tu connais une question
internet connaiss connaissent-il le
formulaire de remboursement de la taxe
pour Cob
Ouais je vais je vais y venir c'est pas
une taxe
Donc lorsque les les sociétés de gestion
collective viennent financer un
festival, le festival de l'accordéon
magique par exemple qui va être inauguré
par tel député ou tel sénateur, hein,
qui va intervenir, qui va couper le le
ruban et cetera, et bien ce ce mécanisme
là d'influence permet aussi finalement
de créer une certaine solidarité entre
le milieu de la culture et le milieu
politique. Et ça peut expliquer
notamment pourquoi lorsque les sociétés
de gestion collective ont eu besoin de
soutien politique, le soutien politique
a toujours été là. Au-delà,
ça c'est ton interprétation.
Alors c'est c'est enfin
Jean-No Tron dit plus ou moins cela
outre le fait que outre le fait que
ça ça supute là. Non, parce que j'ai
j'ai plus l'expression en tête, mais je
je te livrerai la vidéo et tu tu as ça.
C'està-dire que c'est un instrument,
c'est un levier important de solidarité
entre le le politique et la culture.
Mais pour le coup, enfin c'est c'est un
c'est un secret de polichinel. J'ai il
suffit de lire ce qui se raconte sur
Twitter. Là, il y a il y a eu des
échanges assez viriles euh autour de la
Ça veut dire quoi virile ?
Euh menaçant et discourtoi
menant
euh et où euh si tu veux le le le
ça veut pas dire ça virile.
La la menace était à peine voilée et où
ça disait en gros euh toi si tu votes
pas comme il faut, il y aura pas de
festival dans ta circonscription.
Ah sur Twitter ça ?
Ouais. Ah tuas tu as eu des échanges
comme ça.
alors je je sais plus lequel des des
rituels Eric Botorel a subi des des
menaces de ce type là sur les festival
où il a fait il a été fait état des des
positions d'Éric Botorel au regard du
sujet de ce sujet-là alors que celui-ci
demandait simplement le béabas à savoir
un peu de transparence et qui serait
bien d'avoir un rapport qui évolue
aujourd'hui la pertinence de ce
dispositif euh en 2021 après
Jésus-Christ et parce que aujourd'hui
bah moi quand je lis le rapport du Snap
qui est le syndicat national de
l'édition phonographique. Celui-ci
s'enchante rapport après rapport du
changement de paradigme actuel, à savoir
qu'on est passé de donc cette logique de
de stock à une logique de flux où
aujourd'hui bah il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde qui est abonné sur des
plateformes possiblement payantes type
Spotify, ou autre ou YouTube Premium et
tous les autres machins de ce type. Euh
voilà parce que ces gens n'ouvent
n'éprouvent plus le besoin d'empiler des
fichiers pour se les conserver de
manière jalouse.
Sachez les autres. Voilà, il ils sont
ils sont là au Non mais attends, il faut
il faut comprendre quand tu fais du
streaming
euh il y a une rémunération, c'est pas
une copie privée du streaming. Quand tu
écoutes de la de la vidéo sur YouTube,
de la musique sur Spotify, déjà tu payes
un abonnement et il y a une une belle
part de l'abonnement qui va rémunérer
les mêmes SASM, Spedyam, Scam et autres.
Tu vois, tous ces gens-là sont payés.
Quand tu écoutes en streaming, il y a
une partie du revenu de la plateforme,
que ce soit du revenu publicitaire ou du
revenu d'abonnement qui est reversé.
Donc ça c'est pas de la copie privée,
c'est du monopole. Ça c'est ça c'est lié
au monopole du droit d'auteur. Et donc
ta redevance copie privée, elle sert à
financer uniquement la musique que tu
enregistres sur ton téléphone,
ta carte SD bidule, ton disque dur, le
laptop, la tablette, l'ordinateur du
travail, la télé,
les vidéos ou les textes et cetera et
cetera. Donc faut faut bien comprendre
quand tu passes du téléchargement au
streaming,
la il y a plus de copie privée et comme
il y a plus de copie privée, la
redevance devient euh infondée ou mal
fondée.
Quand quand ils se gargarisent du fait
que on passe d'un système où les gens
téléchargeaient à un système où les gens
regardent en streaming et où du coup
qu'est-ce que c'est vachement mieux, bah
oui, sauf que du coup ils te disent que
il y a plus de copie privée mais en même
temps curieusement la redevance copie
privée continue d'augmenter.
Sachant que les producteurs de musique
siège au commission copie privée. Mais
euh alors tout à l'heure je je
t'expliquais, je te disais que la
redonnance copie privée n'est pas
prélevée chez le distributeur entre le
distributeur et le consommateur mais au
plus haut niveau de la chaîne
commerciale.
Et ça a une contrainte ou ça en tout cas
ça ça a un effet évidemment accidentel,
c'est de faire collecter la redevance
copie privée par l'ensemble des des du
commerce de support en France, hein. Que
le que le que la tablette, que le le DVD
vierge et cetera et cetera finisse sa
vie dans les tiroirs d'un particulier ou
dans une entreprise ou une association
ou une église ou un hôpital ou un
établissement public ou un ministère ou
une collectivité locale et cetera et
cetera. Donc tout le monde pay. Alors,
ce qui s'est passé, c'est que euh les
AANO donc euh bah se satisfaisait très
bien de ce régime-là, sauf que bah le
Conseil d'État est intervenu il y a
quelques années de cela euh bientôt 10
ans et il est intervenu euh pour dire
bah non, on peut pas mélanger, donc il
faut impérativement que les études
d'usage notamment fassent le distingo
entre les copies personnelles et les
copies professionnelles. Il faut il faut
pas de copie privée sur les flux
professionnels. Et le législateur est
intervenu en 2011
sur demande du Conseil d'État et il a
prévu effectivement un régime de
remboursement ou d'exonération. Alors ce
remboursement, il a il est assez drôle
puisque finalement les professionnels
sont obligés d'abord de payer leur
support à plein pot, c'estàdire prix du
support plus redevance copie privée,
mais ensuite de lancer une procédure
pour obtenir remboursement de ce qu'il
n'avait pas à payer. Tu suis ? Attends,
c'est pas fini. Et très
accidentellement, très curieusement ou
de manière très très responsable parce
que le ministère de la culture sans
doute a voulu s'assurer de la du bon
respect de des normes, le ministère la
culture a publié euh un texte
d'application pour conditionner le
remboursement de la redevance copie
privée à la fourniture d'une facture
mentionnant le poids de la redevance
copie privée.
Alors là, on va parler de de vie très
concrète là encore.
Vas-y.
Euh tu peux lui prêter ta appel ? Oui
oui
oui. Vas-y, vas-y. On on avait amené un
tunnelier chacun. Oui oui oui.
Go.
Donc euh
quand on te dit que euh le professionnel
peut évidemment se faire rembourser la
renovance copie privée qu'il n'avait pas
payé sur les supports qu'il a acheté
pour son taf hein, pas pour copier
l'intégral de de Rikazaray. Euh et bien
ça
est-ce que c'est bien Rikazaray ? Mais
j'ai pensé à toi. Tu n'as pas arrêté de
me me vanter cette cet artiste par SMS
dans le jeu ?
Je suis en ce moment chez plus ma
période Nana Mouscouri.
Ah et ben écoute euh et euh quand le le
professionnel professionnel veut se
faire rembourser, il a l'obligation de
fournir une facture mentionnant le poids
de la redevance.
Ce qui veut dire par là, c'est que le
distributeur chez qui il a acheté le
support et bien il est un système de
facturation qui puisse fournir le poids
de la redevance hein. Tout tout simple.
Bon, maintenant euh pour connaître le
tarif en question, il faut aller sur le
site de Copiefrance euh copiefrance.fr
et en bas à gauche, tu as tarif
applicable.
Et le tarif, tu verras qu'il y a trois
pages, il y a un PDF de trois pages avec
des échelles, des taux, des machins, des
trucs. C'est trois pages remplies de de
tarifs différents différenciés.
Qu'est-ce que tu essayes de me dire là ?
Est-ce que c'est complexifié à dessin
pour éviter que les gens se fassent
rembourser pour qu'il y en a qui s'en
mettent un peu plus dans les poches pour
redistribuer un peu ? Je dis juste que
je dis est-ce que c'est un dessin ? Je
ne sais pas. En tout cas c'est compliqué
parce que tu as trois pages de tarif et
ces trois pages de tarif doivent être
ingurgité par l'ensemble des systèmes de
facturation en France.
Que ce soit que ce soit la petite
boutique la petite boutique qui vend des
clés USB machin des cartes mémoires que
la la grande que le le carrefour ou
Auchamp du coin peu importe. hein. Et je
te mets au défi là de faire un test,
d'acheter un petit support, une petite
boutique du coin ou autre pour tes
besoins pro hein. Euh et puis demander à
la personne qui te vend ça de te fournir
une facture qui mention sur le poid de
la redevance. note
bah faites un test et tu verras que bah
assez souvent bizarrement
parce que nous on en achète beaucoup des
trucs comme ça
puisque puisque c'est ces images
enregistr nos tipur de de pouvoir nous
nous aider sur
à payer à copie privée pour vos besoins
professionnels h et
qu'on devrait se faire rembourser
d'ailleurs.
Bah oui mais pour vous faire rembourser
il faut cette facture. Donc vérifiez
je te prends au mot je te prends au mot.
OK. Et ben vérifiez vos factures. Tu
regardes le si
on se rend compte que c'est vraiment une
usine à gaz qu'on a l'impression d'être
entre le Burkina Faso de 1960 et le
Gabon de 1978.
Oh, tu es juste dans Brésil, cherche pas
plus loin.
Sérieux ?
Sérieux, sérieux. C'est fait à dessin.
Enfin, je faut pas croire que ce soit
euh on
peut pas on peut pas se permettre de
dire que c'est
on peut pas savoir s'il y a une
intention. Mais enfin, il n'empêche que
quand l'administration veut que ça
fonctionne, par exemple la TVA qui
fonctionne sur exactement le même
principe, l'administration a fait en
sorte que ce soit d'un bout à l'autre.
Depuis la première facture d'importation
jusqu'à la dernière facture grand
public, c'est une obligation de
mentionner la TVA. Donc si la redevance
copie privée, on avait voulu que ça
fonctionne, ben en fait ça ça figurerait
sur les factures de l'importateur et ce
serait transféré sur toutes les factures
sur toute la chaîne au même titre que la
TVA. Et si tu veux, par exemple, aux
États-Unis, tu as deux taux de TVA. Tu
as le taux de TVA de l'État et le taux
de TVA fédéral. Et donc toutes les
facteurs des États-Unis, il y a deux
taux de TVA parce que tu as deux, tu
payes de la TVA à deux endroits. Tu
pourrais très bien avoir en France sur
les factures une ligne sur la TVA et une
ligne redevance copie privée et sur
toutes les factures, même le ticket de
caisse de ton boulanger, il y a la TVA
parce que c'est une obligation légale.
Si faire figurait la relevance copie
privée, on avait voulu que ça marche sur
cette mécanique de remboursement qui est
déjà un peu bizarre,
tu aurais une obligation légale de faire
figurer une ligne redevance de copie
privée qui s'applique qui s'imposerait à
tous les acteurs de la chaîne et on sait
le faire. On le fait pour la TVA, on
peut le faire pour autre chose.
Mais cette obligation, cette obligation
existe sauf qu'elle est pas appliquée.
Jamais.
Mais donc c'est c'est ça le point, c'est
en fait cette obligation n'existe que
pour l'acteur en fin de chaîne, pas pour
les acteurs intermédiaires et que pour
ceux qui veulent se faire rembourser.
Et donc en fait ça existe pour des cas
qui sont extrêmement marginaux et on a
fait en sorte que ça reste extrêmement
marginal et on a fait en sorte on n pas
fait en sorte que ça marche bien et en
terme administratif quand tu fais pas en
sorte que ça marche bien spontanément ça
marche mal.
Ah il y a des acteurs intelligents qui
arrivent Apple par exemple fournit une
facture avec le poids de la redovance.
Donc si jamais tu veux acheter un
produit Apple euh une petite boutique du
coin ou sur le site apple.fr, ben moi je
te recommande d'acheter plutôt sur
apple.fr. FR euh parce que là tu auras
une facture avec mention de la RCP de la
redevance copie privée
qu'on peut se faire rembourser
que tu pourras te faire rembourser alors
que j'ai la petite boutique du coin.
Alors auprès de qui après il faut aller
remplir le formulaire CERFA 28 32 non il
faut remplir un formulaire ou un un
process en ligne. C'est un comptable qui
fait ça
copiefrance.fr. Voilà il faut fournir la
facture et cetera et cetera. Mais euh
évidemment, il faut comprendre une
chose, c'est que si ce traitement-là
pour ta clé USB va te prendre euh je
sais pas 1h 1h30 2h, voilà, pour
quelques quelques dizaines de centimes
ou quelques euros, tu vas pas le faire
parce que tu tu perds trop de le gain
est minime, il est ridicule, il est même
nul.
Question internet, on on tu es sorti de
ton tunnel ou
je peux y rentrer quand tu veux.
Bon, on va on va voir. Question
internet. Savez-vous des informations
sur l'origine des incendies dans les
serveurs OVH à la veille de leur
introduction en bourse et du choix d'un
opérateur pour le cloud souverain
notamment dans le cadre de GAA X data
gouvernance acte. Désolé je reviens sur
ce sujet précédent.
question de des tram
non et j'avoue que dans mon tunnel j'ai
oublié de parler des bien des biens
reconditionnés mais on pour reparler
après mais
ouais non pour les bien reconditionnés
en fait et
non si je si je te fais ce ce long
tableau là c'est te dire que venir
ensuite et arriver avec le sujet des
biens reconditionnés euh
dire que c'est pour l'écologie c'est du
foutage de gueule
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que euh
au Sénat avait été adopté un article 14
10 B la proposition de loi destinée à à
alléger l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique où il était expliqué que il y
a pas de redonnance copie privée sur les
biens remis en ligne enfin remis sur le
marché par reconditionnement parce que
ça a déjà été payé une fois.
Ça a été payé une fois. Bon après on
pourrait dire que c'est racheté, il y a
des nouveaux usages et cetera et cetera
mais il s'agissait de de verdir le
numérique de faire en sorte de de pas
trop déconner avec ce dispositif. Et ça
c'était très mal vécu par les aandroits,
d'autant plus que ceci avait mené à bien
une série d'attaques à l'encontre de de
TPE et PME. Et ce qui s'est passé euh en
en séance à l'Assemblée nationale, c'est
que sur
demande pressente, on appelle ça
lobbying à Bruxelles, mais sur lobbying
extrêmement poussé des sociétés
collectives, le gouvernement a renversé
la vapeur. C'est-à-dire que plutôt que
de dire on préserve l'économie du
reconditionné de cette cette redevance
culturelle, mais finalement on va
l'autoriser. Et donc il a prévu tout le
nid le nid législatif pour bâtir ce
barême administratif sur cette économie
reconditionnée. Et ça c'est un exploit
franchement c'est un exploit sémantique
politique juridique tactique que dans
une proposition de loi destine à verdir
le numérique. on en vient à créer et à
installer une redevance qui va ben sans
doute faire très très plaisir euh aux
cultureux, aux industries culturelles,
mais qui va flinguer une partie alors
quel taux, je sais pas, mais une partie
des des TPE ou des PME du secteur hein.
C'est un miracle pour moi. C'est enfin
c'est c'est on est digne des JO là en
terme de
bienvenue en France. Ouais. En terme de
technique de lobbying, c'est superbe.
Euh, tu vois le le Sénat avait compris
la question qui était euh l'empreinte
écologique du numérique, c'est à 70 ou
80 % la fabrication du terminal. Ton
ordinateur portable, ton ordinateur
fixe, ta tablette, ton téléphone, ta
télé, tout ça. Et donc faire en sorte de
favoriser le la filière du
reconditionné. Donc le fait qu'on
récupère les téléphones anciens, on les
répare un petit peu, on change la
batterie s'ils sont trop vieux, quand
c'est possible, on amélior, on clean un
peu le truc et puis on le revend d'occas
à pas cher. Euh ça c'est hyper vertueux
parce que tu évites de fabriquer un
terminal euh plutôt que de le [__] à
la poubelle et puis d'en fabriquer un
autre. Donc c'est très intéressant et ce
que ce que le Sénat avait compris c'est
OK, il faut qu'on fasse baisser au
maximum le prix des téléphones euh
revendus et remis en circulation et un
des bons moyens c'était de dire pas de
redevance copie privée puisque de toute
façon elle a déjà été payée quand le
truc a été est rentré sur le marché. Euh
et c'est c'est de repérer en combien de
temps le la pression a été faite sur les
députés pour switcher le truc avec
l'aval du ministère de la culture qui
qui au départ de trouver plutôt que
c'était pas con. euh de faire un truc un
peu écolo. C'était pas son sujet. Euh
c'est enfin je crois que je crois que je
sais même pas si le ministère de la
culture a été impliqué au départ dans ce
texte là. En fait, le ministère culture
a toujours défendu la redevance copie
privée parce que au regard des 25 %
copie privée, chaque fois que les
sociétés de gestion collective financent
du festival, c'est de l'argent public en
moins.
Donc il trouvent un intérêt.
Mais tu vois le le le point de bascule
pour entre le passage au Sénat et le
passage à l'Assemblée retourner le truc
et mais va va regarder les échanges sur
Twitter, c'est d'une beauté magnifique.
Après, il y a eu cette pétition.
Un petit exemple.
Il y a il y a les menaces contre Éric
Botorel. Je sais plus qui qui était le
plus menaçant. Est-ce que c'était Pascal
Regard Hervéroni, je sais plus lequel.
Des instructions avec ces menaces ou
c'était juste des noms d'oiseaux envoyés
en l'air ?
Ah bah non, c'est pas des noms d'oiseaux
envoyés en l'air. Enfin, c'est c'est des
menaces assez claires contre un type qui
est député. Enfin, il est député le mec,
il est représentant du peuple quand
même. C'est pas Jo Clodo.
Euh et et on et on vient lui laisser
entendre que peut-être il y aura un peu
moins de festival dans sa
circonscription parce qu'il est pas
sage. Je c'est des méthodes de malfra.
Sachant que au même moment, il y a eu le
C'est ça qui a été dit.
Oui.
Ouais. Et au même moment, il y a eu
J'ai pas vu les échanges, c'est ils sont
super intéressants à les regarder. Et
en fait, j'ai fait, tu pourras lire un
film, j'ai fait une espèce de manuelle
du du lobbying où tu vois qu'il y a des
voilà, il y a des il y a différentes il
y a des menaces larvées, hein. J'espère
que j'espère que les les acteurs
culturels du département ou de la
circonscription
prendront soin de bien voir ce qu'a fait
Éric Botorel pour défendre leur
rémunération, hein.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc donc c'est bien
tourné. C'est ouv
c'est une interprétation que c'est pas
une menace.
Bah en tout cas quand ça se répète quand
ça se répète quand ça se répète sur
plusieurs jours.
Toi qui n'a pas payé l'impôt
révolutionnaire, j'espère qu'il n'y aura
pas d'incendie chez toi. C'est pas une
menace. Je te souhaite le bien
comprends-tu ?
Ouais. Non mais là ce qui ce qui est
super intéressant comme épisode aussi
dans le dans comme épisode c'est la la
fameuse pétition du JDD. Alors le JDD a
titré 1661 artistes signent une pétition
pour défendre la redevance copie privée
sur le reconditionné. Mais en tout cas,
il parlait de 1661 artistes. Alors parmi
les 1661 artistes effectivement on avait
des artistes mais dedans, on avait aussi
une juriste, on avait des directeurs, on
en avait des on avait un enfin des des
responsables de de société de gestion
gestion collective, des administrateurs
et cetera. Bon euh et ce qui est
marrant, c'est que dans le texte qui a
précédé cette pétition euh il était mis
en avant comme ça ce fameux back market,
ce machin là qui vend du reconditionné
qui vient de lever 276 millions d'euros,
vous voyez ? Enfin donc ça a une espèce
d'ogre qui machin capitaliste qui vient
gloutonner vos votre rémunération.
D'abord, c'est pas une rémunération,
c'est pas une taxe, c'est une indemnité.
Booum ! La preuve,
la gueule ton studio.
Euh
donc déjà c'est pas une rémunération
révolutionnaire, c'est pour ça.
Ouais. Et en plus ce qui est vachement
intéressant c'est que Back Market qui a
été qui a été épinglé pour sa puissance
financière, bon ils ont levé des levé
276 millions de fonds d'euros de fonds.
Mais surtout c'est pas un
reconditionneur, c'est une marketplace.
Donc c'est pas eux qui sont en train
avec le tournevis en train de de
rectifier la batterie ou l'écran ou
autre. Non non, ils sont c'est une
plateforme de de vendeurs vers des
acheteurs. Donc ils sont pas redevables.
Pas redevables.
C'est pas eux qui vont payer.
C'est le consommateur à la fin qui paye
toujours.
Oui, ça Oui, mais ça toujours.
Et revenons à ma question. Avez-vous des
informations sur l'origine de l'incendie
dans les serveurs ? La veille de son
l'origine de l'incendie. Non, moi j'ai
pas d'info. Euh pour le coup, faudrait
demander ça à Otave et je sais pas s'il
en a ou enquêteurs. Je sais pas si si
les enquêteurs ont des indices.
On va appeler Octave. Euh Octave Claba,
monsieur Octave Claba, enfin Octave,
quoi. Euh, merde, on l'appelle Octave
depuis qu'il est sur Usennet. Ça va
bien, quoi. Euh
et euh et l'autre partie de la question
sur cloud souverain euh et cetera et
cetera, euh
les acteurs américains essayent de
Alors, GAI, c'est une initiative
européenne dont je n'arrive pas encore à
savoir si un jour ce sera autre chose
qu'une
qu'un outil de lobbying.
Nous, on était sur Cyberga.
Et donc GA X euh c'est un outil qui
prétend vouloir mettre en place une
norme des norme un peu interopérable
entre opérateur de cloud pour que toi
client tu puisses passer d'un opérateur
à l'autre travailler sur plusieurs en
même temps avoir des choses qui se
ressemblent un peu, un peu de qualité de
service de trois bricoles comme ça et il
se trouve que le siège est à Bruxelles
et que pour le moment ça fait quand même
beaucoup du lobbing.
Et donc dans ce machin là, comme c'est à
Bruxelles et qu'il y a pas mal de
lobbing, bah tu as évidemment tous les
acteurs américains présents jusque et y
compris pasalentir.
Mais Google, Amazon,
tout le monde tout le monde est là.
Enfin, ils sont tous là.
Euh
c'est un pour le moment c'est un outil
relativement classique de lobbying
américain, de lobby européen et donc les
Américains, ils sont présents. Euh
cependant, ça a été apparemment pas trop
mal pensé dans le dans les structures.
J'ai pas été vérifié les détails, mais
il se trouve que au board de Ga X, tu
n'as pas de grands acteurs américains.
Euh ils sont membres mais ils sont pas
au board et en fait ils peuvent pas être
au bord. Euh donc ça c'est quand même
une légère euh nuance mais pour le
moment Ga X n'a n'a pas produit euh quoi
que ce soit d'util. Euh c'est juste une
déclaration d'intention. Et euh moi je
suis dans dans ce genre de de truc-là,
je reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure hein. Euh moi il me manque une
politique économique. En France, il y a
pas la volonté.
Non, une politique économique, bordel de
Dieu. Euh le fait qu'on ait des écoles,
le fait qu'on s'arrange pour qu'il y ait
une filière économique, le fait qu'on
lui crée des déboucher, qu'on utilise la
commande publique pour faire tourner les
Turnes françaises et pas pour acheter de
la licence Microsoft. Le fait que
l'armée s'équipe plutôt avec des
logiciels qui sont codés en France qu'en
achetant systématiquement du Microsoft.
Bah, tu vois, la gendarmerie avait fait
l'effort il y a une dizaine d'années de
passer ses postes sur Ubuntu et de
passer ça sur du logiciel libre.
Et tu vois, bah il y a et ça et ça
supposait toute une démarche parce que
bah effectivement il fallait refaire un
peu les formations de tout le monde, il
fallait adapter la gestion de la
bureautique du machin n na enfin ça
demandait un petit effort mais il y
avait un sens. Ça disait le business il
aura lieu en France. Ça veut dire que la
boîte qui fait le support pour la
gendarmerie de toutes les questions
bureautiques ou buntu et cetera, cette
entreprise là, c'est une boîte
française. Si tu achètes le support à
Microsoft, tu transfères ce pognon là
aux États-Unis et donc tu transfères la
l'activité économique et tu ne
développes pas une filière économique en
France.
Et en plus, tu te rends esclave
en plus. Mais si tu veux, tuas tu as un
fond de macroéconomie, mais on connaît
ça depuis le 19e siècle hein. Je te
parle pas d'un truc hyper hyper évolué.
le fait que tout d'importation se
traduit par une montée du chômage et que
tout d'exportation se traduit par une
baisse du chômage. Je on connaît ça
depuis les économistes de la 2e moitié
du 19e siècle. C'est en gros si tu
achètes des fringues que tu as importé,
la seule plus-value qui rentre dans ton
économie, c'est celle de l'importateur
et celle du marchand. Si en fait tu
importes du tissu et que le la fringue
est cousue dans ton espace économique,
alors la plusvalue que tu encaisse,
c'est celle du couturier, celle de de
l'importateur du tissu et celle du
marchand. Si au lieu d'importer du
tissu, tu tu importes du fil, tu auras
en plus la plus-value du tisseran. Si au
lieu d'importer du fil, tu importes la
matière première, tu auras en plus la
plusvalue de la filature. Et si au lieu
d'importer quoi que ce soit, tu fais
pousser ton lin, ton coton et tes
moutons chez toi, tu auras même la
plusvalue de l'agriculteur chez toi.
Donc et ça c'est connu depuis le 19e
siècle. Enfin, c'est tu as ça dans le
Capital Carl Marx chapitre 1. C'est
Et d'ailleurs, on est en train de
designer nos goodies parce que tout le
monde nous réclame des goodies Syerview,
mais on est en train de les
brodeuses à Orléon, avec un coton qui
est fait dans les dans les règles de
l'art du Mine France à tu j'aurais aimé
qu'il y ait une stratégie économique de
la part du gouvernement. Il se trouve
que le l'Europe a produit un cadre
réglementaire qui crée du
protectionnisme
puisque tu as deux façons de faire du
protectionnisme. Tu as le
protectionnisme douanier où on met les
droits de douane et tu as le
protectionnisme réglementaire où on fait
en sorte que la réglementation pourrisse
la vie des gens qui sont pas de chez
nous. C'est pour ça que tu as pas les
mêmes formats de prises électriques
partout dans le monde parce que du coup
ça complique un peu la vie. Il faut que
tu te réadaptes et du coup tu peux
difficilement aller vendre en
Grande-Bretagne ce que tu as fabriqué
pour la France et cetera. Ça c'est connu
de pareil depuis le 19e siècle, le fait
queon peut faire du protectionnisme ou
bien par le tarif doigné ou bien par la
réglementation. Et donc l'Europe a fait
une réglementation qui crée un effet
protectionniste. J'aurais aimé que les
Étatsmembres se saisissent de cette
réglementation pour faire de la de la
politique économique.
Non mais
et ils font pas de politique économique.
Leur politique économique c'est de
servir la soupe aux Américains.
Et sur ces mots, on arrive à la fin de
notre interview. Est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ? Et
avant ce conseil pour les jeunes
générations, je voudrais trois livres
chacun.
Trois livres.
Trois livres et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Allez Marc et on finira sur Ben.
Il y a un livre en écriture perpétuelle,
journal officiel.
Ah pieuse lecture.
Pieuse lecture.
C'est parfait pour s'endormir le soir.
Euh non non non mais j'insiste,
j'insiste
deux décrets devant le Conseil d'État et
tu dors.
Ouais, j'insiste, j'insiste. Euh le
suivi des amendements à l'Assemblée
nationale, j'insiste mais je fais
exprès. Et euh qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait
y avoir encore ? Euh next impact. Ça pas
on a pas le droit à ça. Et ben OK, ben
je le fais alors du coup. J'adore
j'adore violer les règles. Non non, j'ai
j'ai j'insiste vraiment parce que le le
problème c'est que euh enfin on est face
à une à une montagne normative hein
euh qui est en plus matiné de d'un
marketing qui qui part dans tous les
sens et c'est extrêmement compliqué que
de que de détricoter tout ça. on se perd
facilement et on fait on se fait
facilement papaouter par tout le monde
et c'est c'est vraiment compliqué que de
suivre ce travail parlementaire alors
qu'en fait c'est l'avenir notre avenir
leur avenir qui se dessine sous leur pas
et essayer de de comprendre chacun de
ces pas là chacun de ces ces amendements
qu'est-ce que ça implique qu'est-ce que
ça je trouve que c'est c'est quand même
important et en plus ça participe aussi
la citoyenneté de chacun qui peut
ensuite ben ben acquérir suffisamment de
compétences pense pour pour parler par
exemple comme un comme un Benjamin qui
va qui va avoir une vista, une vue sur
les différents grands mouvements de de
glacier comme ça qui se déroule devant
nous et et je pense que ça le le la
compréhension de ces de ces de ces ces
rouages là est super importante. Ça
évite vraiment enfin moi ce que j'adore
faire par exemple ce que je fais depuis
depuis tout le temps, enfin en tout cas
ce que j'essaie de faire depuis tout le
temps, c'est de d'avoir d'avoir un
maître un ruban un maître ruban et de
mesurer la distance qu'il y a entre la
parole politique et puis le réaliser
l'acte hein. On l'a vu par exemple entre
les débats parlementaires
h
et les taxes d'application sur le pass
sanitaire. Donc et en fait c'est super
important de ça parce que
ça tu déprimes pas trop.
Non, je déprime pas trop parce que j'ai
j'ai une confiance. J'ai une certaine
confiance et puis une certaine peut-être
naïveté aussi. Mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est déprimant parce que l'empinement
de de ces ces grands maîtres rubans,
ça ça peut faire peur mais euh mais
c'est vraiment important pour comprendre
le monde le enfin en tout cas une partie
du monde qui nous entoure.
Benjamin, trois livres et un conseil
pour les jeunes générations.
Alors trois livres euh
euh
d'abord lire Ursula le gain. Euh il y a
il y a tout un volet fantaisie dans dans
ce qu'elle a écrit qui qui s'appelle
Termè. Il y a deux trilogie dans Termère
et puis il y a tout un volet qui est
plus science-fiction,
utopie, dystopie et cetera. C'est
extrêmement intéressant. C'est très
rafraîchissant comme lecture et tout est
bien. Donc tout Ursula le gain, tu vois,
je vais le compter comme un livre. Donc
là, je viens defler parce qu'il y en a
genre 15.
Euh
j'aime oui, je sais que tu aimes ça.
C'est c'est c'est pour ça. C'est c'est
pour ça. Euh je crois je crois qu'il est
extrêmement important de lire,
surveiller et punir de Michel Fouco.
Je crois que tu peux pas comprendre
l'espèce de politique complètement
paranoïque dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui.
Si tu as pas lu surveiller et punir de
Michel Fou. Alors si tu t'ennuies, tu
peux en lire d'autres aussi. Je trouve
que les les deux vol trois volumes de
l'histoire de la sexualité sont aussi
extrêmement intéressants euh parce que
il il pareil ils analysent beaucoup ce
que c'est que le le c'est cette espèce
de surveillance sociale qui va avec.
Enfin
le plus facile d'accès, c'est surveiller
et punir et les les trois volumes
éventuellement de l'histoire de la
sexualité sont un peu moins faciles
d'accès. Et puis un troisème livre
euh l'histoire d'un allemand. J'ai
oublié le nom de l'auteur, mais internet
le retrouvera très facilement. Le livre
s'appelle Histoire d'un allemand
et c'est un récit autobiographique
d'un jeune homme allemande dans les
années 30 en Allemagne qui va fuir
en en 38 ou 39.
Sébastien Afner.
Ouais, Sébastien Affner, histoire d'un
allemand. Euh c'est fou, c'est fou. Euh,
il faut le lire parce que ça te raconte
et il se trouve que le le l'histoire du
bouquin le l'histoire de comment le
bouquin est apparu, comment il a été
retrouvé dans dans le grenier du mec,
jamais publié, on avait le manuscrit euh
on avait oublié qu'il l'avait écrit,
enfin truc de dingue. Et c'est un récit
autobiographique d'époque
et qui te raconte la montée du nazisme
et qui te raconte comment un pays
devient fou et paranoïque et comment le
pays fou et paranoïque se met enfin
sombre complètement et je trouve ça
effrayant à lire parce que ça ressemble
beaucoup à l'époque moderne
et je pense qu'il faut enfin tu vois
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant à
lire. C'est pas pareil. C'est différent
temps. Oui. Quand on a encore le temps,
c'est différent. C'est pas pareil.
L'Allemagne des années 30 et la France
des années 20, c'est pas la même chose.
Mais il y a des points communs très
grands, très forts. Euh par exemple le
fait qu'on ait élu une classe politique
qui néglige les institutions, qui
néglige les contrepouvoirs et qui
veulent aller vite et donner raison au
chef. Dans le nazisme, c'était parce que
c'était M fur et dans le macronisme,
c'est pas
de parallèle. Pas de parallèle. Mais
non. parce qu'il faut obéir au chef et
parce que le modèle le modèle sur lequel
il se réfère, c'est l'entreprise. Or, il
y a pas moins démocratique qu'une
entreprise. Une entreprise c'est un
système où le patron a dit et tout le
monde fait. Quand c'est ça ta référence,
ta référence c'est d'obéir au chef.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Mais pour le coup, j'en avais déjà donné
les les dernières fois et je crois que
je vais rester sur ce que j'avais dit.
Il faut se passionner. Il faut se
passionner pour n'importe quoi. Ça peut
être l'élevage de la crevette en eau
douce.
la culture des petits poids, le tricot,
l'informatique, la lutte cont pour les
libertés, comprendre l'environnement
juridique, technique, social,
construire des ponts,
construire des ponts. Faites de la
sociologie, faites de la sociologie,
faites de Faites de l'anthropologie
politique.
C'est passionnant l'anthropologie
politique. Comprend nulle part, ça mène
nulle part. Si ça amène à comprendre le
monde. Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire de
faire en terme professionnel t tous les
Mais en terme professionnel, tu iras tu
iras faire n'importe quoi comme tout le
monde.
Ça tous les sociologues de la Sorbonne
qui qui font des voix de garage. C'est
ça.
L'anthropologie politique, c'est la
science qui te permet de comprendre les
structures sous-jacentes à tous les
systèmes politiques de toutes les
sociétés humaines. C'est fabuleusement
intéressant. Il y a rien de plus
intéressant que ça au monde.
Donc voilà, faites des choses,
passionnez-vous pour ce que vous faites.
Messieurs, merci. Attends, attends,
attends. Quoi ?
Un conseil pour
non. Lire le journal officiel, ça compte
pas comme conseil. Ça c'était Non, ça
c'était nul. Non, lire toutigusi,
auteur de BD. Je suis un grand fan de
BD. Donc Tanyigoshi, Yvon Roi
Blanquette, manteau de neige. Moi c'est
je je baigne dans la BD en fait, je lis
trop je lis trop de textes la journée.
Donc le soir, je lis des images et je
voilà. Donc
conseil pour les jeunes générations,
bah euh
d'être prudent et puis de pas croire
tout ce qu'on dit et notamment les
conseils conseils de lecture et euh non
mais
euh ouais de faire attention avant de
voter puis de de vérifier cette
machinerie infernale parce que ça va
très vite et beaucoup de bêtises sont
dites et et
ne pas croire les pétitions.
Messieurs, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]